le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la reconstruction des
bâtiments dégradés ou démolis au cours
des violences urbaines survenues du 27
juin au 5 juillet 2023 la procédure
accélérée a été engagée sur ce texte
j'informe le Sénat
que les candidatures pour siéger au sein
de l'éventuelle commission mixte
paritaire sur ce texte ont été publiés
ces candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement et je rappelle à chacune
et à chacun que si naturellement il y a
commission mix paritaire y aurait séance
vendredi prochain pour la lecture des
conclusions je sens que ça fait monter
l'ambiance merci
dans la discussion générale la parole
est d'abord à Monsieur le Ministre
Christophe bichut ministre de la
cohésion de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
ce président madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
du 27 juin au 5 juillet notre pays a été
marqué par des nuits de violences et de
pillage inqualifiables dont l'étendue
des destructions surpasse le tri
précédent record des émeutes de 2005
sous la conduite du président de la
République et de la première ministre
nous étions engagés à ce que un texte
permet de répondre aux besoins de
travaux d'urgence et je tiens à saluer
le travail du Sénat au cours de ces
dernières heures et plus largement
l'état d'esprit avec lequel ce texte a
été accueilli pour porter un ensemble de
mesures qui relève de la loi au delà de
la circulaire qui a été publiée pour
faire face plus rapidement à l'urgence
de la reconstruction matérielle en
levant un certain nombre de verrous
je vous le dis tout de suite
ce que n'est pas ce texte c'est une
réponse globale à la situation que nous
avons connue nous ne sommes pas sur les
causes nous sommes clairement sur les
conséquences et sur le fait de faire en
sorte dans l'urgence
pour la liste limité des bâtiments qui
ont été touchés et pendant les jours qui
séparent le 27 juin du 5 juillet de
mettre en place des dispositions qui
permettent d'aller plus vite et je
souhaite que
la plus grande puisse se manifester
aujourd'hui comme elle a su se
manifester de façon quasi unanime aux
côtés de toutes les victimes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs si
nous devons parler de chiffres ils sont
trois fois supérieurs à celui des trois
semaines de 2005
le bilan à ce stade estimé à 650
millions d'euros pour les destructions
d'équipements d'infrastructures et bien
privé avec les symboles de la République
qui ont été particulièrement touchés
274 commissariats brigade de gendarmerie
ou poste de police municipale
105 mairies
243 établissements scolaires dont 60
dans lesquels les dégâts sont
particulièrement importants et une
dizaine d'écoles complètement détruites
47 établissements qui relèvent du
ministère de la Justice
3 centres hospitaliers des équipements
urbains des bus des trams des
médiathèques des maisons de quartiers
des crèches des gymnases des maisons de
culture et même des locaux associatifs
autant Dieu précieux
pour apprendre pour bénéficier
d'opportunités pour faire vivre les
promesses de notre République autant
d'équipements et de services essentiels
pour nos concitoyens et qui masque les
attaques ignobles qui ont eu lieu contre
les dépositaires de la force publique
représentant des forces de l'ordre
sapeurs-pompiers élus je ne veux pas
oublier les commerces et les biens
particuliers en particulier les
pharmacies ce sont plus de 1000
commerces vandalisés et pillés avec un
nombre particulièrement élevé de bureau
de tabac qui ont été pris pour cible
mais ces statistiques à vrai dire et
vous le savez mieux qui compte ici ne
pèse que très peu par rapport à ce que
nos concitoyens ont vécu
je pense comme beaucoup d'entre vous à
Vincent Jean Brun dont l'épouse et les
enfants ont été agressés avec une
brutalité et une lâcheté sans nom je
pense aux parents de cette école de
Dijon l'école Champollion partiellement
détruite par un engin incendiaire et
dont les enfants jouaient sur une aire
de jeux adjacente alors que les parents
préparaient la fête de fin d'année je
pense à cette maison de quartier
Angoulême incendie à deux reprises en
trois jours je pense aux équipes de la
mairie de mons-en-barœul attaquer sans
relâche avec un acharnement inouï
pendant des heures au mortier d'artifice
je pense enfin aux gérant de café aux
employés aux propriétaires de commerce
de proximité aux pharmaciens tous ceux
qui se lèvent tôt et qui mène une vie
droite et honnête et qui pourtant durant
ses nuits ont perdu le fruit de leur
labeur
quand ce n'était pas les économies d'une
vie
nous ne lâchons rien
face à ceux que le spectacle de la
destruction facile réjouit ou face à
ceux qui n'auront pas eu le courage de
se joindre à la nécessité d'appeler au
calme nous devons désormais tous au côté
de ceux qui doivent rebâtir
ce projet de loi il a vocation a suscité
au service d'une reconstruction plus
rapide et de qualité une forme d'union
nationale
d'abord parce que ce serait le plus
cinglant des démentis
aux émeutiers
au délinquants au criminel de montrer
que les stigmates des dégâts qu'ils ont
causé ne restent pas ça n'est qu'une
partie de la réponse mais c'est une
réponse quand même
les dégâts causés ont été considérables
et justifiés une action
urgente et concertée de la part des
pouvoirs publics le droit actuel offre
déjà de nombreux mécanismes c'est
l'esprit de la circulaire de la première
ministre mais nous devons aller un peu
plus loin
d'abord pour les bâtiments atteints
souvent anciens l'objectif est de
faciliter la reconstruction dans le cas
de législatif
offert par la reconstruction à
l’identique tout en permettant des
adaptations pour répondre aux nouvelles
exigences en termes de sécurité et bien
sûr d'environnement
ensuite nous proposons d'autoriser le
commencement des travaux préparatoires
tels que démolition terrassement
installation de chantier ou fondation au
plus vite alors même que la demande
d'autorisation est seulement au cours
d'instruction pour gagner un temps
précieux
né accélérer les procédures de
l'autorisation administratives pour
retrouver plus vite les bâtiments que
nous connaissons ne veut pas dire
confondre vitesse et précipitation
et la qualité des instructions ne sera
pas sacrifiée les maires conserveront
naturellement leur pouvoir
d'appréciation et c'est le bon équilibre
que nous avons cherché à préserver
auquel ce texte répond
après ce volet portant sur les règles
d'urbanisme sur la reconstruction plus
spécifique du bâti public faciliter les
marchés publics de travaux dérogés aux
obligations de publicité préalables
permettent un usage plus étendu des
marchés de conception réalisation et le
deuxième volet qui va nous permettre de
remplir ces objectifs
en ce qui concerne le financement nous
vous proposons de rendre possible la
mobilisation du Fonds de compensation
TVA pour les collectivités leur
groupement
les travaux pourront être subventionnés
en totalité de manière dérogatoire et
ces mesures exceptionnelles sont
nécessaires pour répondre à l'urgence de
la situation et permettre une
reconstruction qui soit à la fois
efficace et rapide
je redis que ces mesures sont
temporaires quels sont limitées au seul
bâtiment détruits par les émeubles
qu'elle ne seront pas utilisables
au-delà et que notre objectif est bien
de faire en sorte que nos concitoyens
affectés puissent retrouver des
bâtiments pérennes et durables qui
puissent leur rendre service
l'enjeu c'est bien que ces ordonnances
puissent être promulguées le plus tôt
possible en commençant par celle qui
porte sur les marchés publics pour
lesquels nous prévoyons une échéance qui
soit au plus tard au mois de septembre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je ne serai pas plus long
cet ensemble de mesures
format mon sens un tout cohérent de bon
sens qui permet un choc de la
simplification strictement circonscrit
au besoin des collectivités
territoriales qui ont été les plus
touchées je sais pouvoir compter sur
votre soutien et votre engagement à leur
côté pour faire avancer ce projet de loi
déterminant
je veux dire que reconstruire ça n'est
pas gommé ou effacé
c'est rendre justice à la majorité
silencieuse
c'est ne pas laisser le dernier mot aux
émeutiers pour lesquels la réponse doit
être judiciaire
il y a eu le temps d'urgence et du
retour au calme nous sommes maintenant
dans le temps d'urgence et de la
reconstruction du traitement des
conséquences et viendra bien sûr à la
rentrée
le temps de l'action résolu sur les
causes et sur les politiques à conduire
et sur les dispositifs à ajuster une
action que nous commençons à construire
de façon pragmatique et lucide au
service de notre cohésion sociale
territoriale et national je vous
remercie pour l'accueil que vous avez
réservé à ce projet et je me réjouis que
nous puissions ensemble faire œuvre
législatives efficace et utile
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant madame la Présidente Sophie
prima rapporteur de la commission des
affaires économiques pour 10 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du Sénat monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je me réjouis qui
nous puissions faire aboutir in extremis
et même un peu au-delà d'une extrémiste
ce texte après une première lecture ici
au Sénat chambre des collectivités
territoriales un sénat engagé attentif
et soucieux de soutien que nous devons
apporter aux maires comme nous la signes
l'article 24 de la Constitution attentif
particulièrement à l'occasion
d'événements exceptionnels tels que ceux
que nous avons traversé du 27 juin au 5
juillet dernier aussi je voudrais
sincèrement tous vous remercier d'être
là aujourd'hui sénatrice et sénateurs
administrateur équipe du Sénat vous-même
monsieur le Président pour présider
cette science un peu au-delà de la fin
de notre session les émeutes qui ont
secoué la France à la suite de la mort
du jeune à elle ont débouché sur des
violences intolérables vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre
physique d'abord contre les forces de
l'ordre contre des mers et désormais
contre leur famille nous avons vu
également durant ces émeutes des scènes
de pillage de commerce des incendies de
voitures des feux de poubelles dans les
cages d'escaliers des actes de
vandalisme qui sont une offense à l'état
de droit des destructions qui touchent
durement nos concitoyens dans leur vie
quotidienne ou leur activité
professionnelle nous avons enfin assisté
à la dégradation et au saccage
d'équipements publics mairie école
centre d'action sociale trésorerie poste
de police au total vous l'avez dit plus
de 750 bâtiments publics auraient été
dégradés et plus d'une centaine détruits
partiellement ou en totalité
dans mon département des Yvelines
plusieurs écoles sont parties en fumée
spectacle désolant je pense ce matin à
Nicolas Dainville maire de La Verrière
ou à Catherine arrêt nous mère de
Chanteloup et à bientôt trop souvent
touchés par ces phénomènes mais je pense
aussi mes chers collègues assez mères de
communes qui ne sont pas de grandes
villes avec des quartiers en politique
de la ville qui sont des mers de
communes moyennes calme jamais ou très
peu touché par ce genre d'événements
tout ceci nous révolte tout ceci nous
concerne et nous interroge une fois de
plus la crise est désormais éteinte au
moins en apparence il faudra des mois
pour en analyser les ressorts profonds
et pour trouver des solutions de long
terme nous ne pourrons pas faire
l'économie d'une réflexion en profondeur
monsieur le ministre sur la perte des
autorités celle de la police celle du
maire celle du maître sur le maintien de
l'ordre sur la responsabilité parentale
sur les politiques publiques de logement
d'étudations d'intégration de soutien
social et dans les quartiers de la et
cela dans les quartiers politiques de la
ville et je le répète en dehors de ces
quartiers mais pour l'heure il y a
urgence à reconstruire c'est une urgence
républicaine j'entends et je comprends
la colère de nos concitoyens victimes ou
spectateurs stupéfiés de ces violences
qui ne veulent plus payer du style pour
des dégâts touts souvent pris en charge
par la puissance publique c'est-à-dire
par chacun de nous mais je le répète la
République ne doit pas reculer nous ne
pouvons pas abandonner ces jeunes de 12
ans parfois à la spirale de la violence
plus que jamais avec le retour à un
ordre réaffirmé nous avons besoin
d'écoles de bibliothèques de maisons des
arts d'équipements sportifs qui sont le
socle de l'émancipation républicaine
maximum de 80%. le projet de loi prévoit
en outre un remboursement anticipé de la
TVA aux collectivité afin de pallier à
d'éventuelles problèmes de trésorerie il
prévoit également que des bâtiments
privés notamment les commerces et les
logements puissent bénéficier des
mesures dérogatoires d'urbanisme ce sont
des apports bienvenus nos collègues
Catherine difolco et Vincent de la
exposeront plus précisément le contenu
des articles 2 et 3 en ce qui concerne
l'article premier c'est-à-dire
l'adaptation des règles d'urbanisme le
projet de loi prévoit trois éléments
premièrement étendre des dispositions
qui existent déjà dans le code de
l'urbanisme pour autoriser la
reconstruction ou la réflexion des
bâtiments touchés à l'identique en
tenant compte des règles d'urbanisme en
vigueur au moment de la construction
initiale et non pas des règles
d'urbanisme valables au moment de la
demande de reconstruction le champ des
modifications admises par rapport au
bâtiment détruit sera également élargi
notamment pour améliorer la sécurité
l'accessibilité ou les performances
énergétiques ou environnementales ce
sont des mesures de bon sens
deuxièmement les opérations et travaux
préliminaires comme la démolition ou
l'évaluation et l'évacuation des gravats
pourrait être engagés dès le dépôt de la
demande de permis là non plus aucune
difficulté enfin pour accélérer
l'instruction des demandes
d'autorisation d'urbanisme les délais
seraient réduits et la règle du silence
vos refus renversé dans certains cas
cela vise surtout les accords les avis
et les autorisations préalables qui
peuvent être nécessaires pour bénéficier
des autorisations d'urbanisme CDAC avis
des ABS par exemple de nouveau il s'agit
d'une mesure de bon sens je précise que
les conditions de participation du
public ne seront pas affectées par les
modifications prévues naturellement il
est difficile de savoir parmi ces
mesures quelles évolutions seront
concrètement nécessaires compte tenu du
récent des événements il faut donc finir
d'affiner l'inventaire des dégradations
et laisser au maître d'ouvrage le temps
d'élaborer leur nouveau projet c'est
pourquoi il me semble justifier pour une
fois de recourir à une habilitation
allégérée par ordonnance le sujet est
très technique nécessite l'adaptation de
très nombreuses dispositions qui sont
parfois de nature réglementaire et qui
devront être coordonnées entre elles
pour être pleinement efficiente il me
semble que compte tenu du caractère
consensuel de ces dispositions
l'administration et la mieux placée pour
faire cela vite et bien ensuite le délai
d'habilitation de trois mois est
suffisamment court pour répondre à
l'urgence de la situation est
suffisamment long pour ne pas se priver
de la possibilité de prendre des mesures
complémentaires si des cas particuliers
se présentaient durant l'été j'invite
cependant le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre a écrit ses ordonnances et à
mettre à les mettre en œuvre sans
attendre
une semaine qui viennent pour que les
principales adaptations puissent être
identifiées par la suite pour toutes ces
raisons nous n'avons pas modifié
l'article premier du texte en commission
pas plus que nos collègues de la
commission des finances à l'article 3 et
nos collègues de la commission des lois
non modifiées qu'à la marge l'article 2
je voudrais pour finir une fois n'est
pas coutume mais c'est probablement
parce que c'est ma dernière intervention
de présidente de commission je voudrais
remercier le gouvernement d'avoir prémi
aurait permis un dialogue fructueux avec
ses services lors de l'élaboration du
texte et je voudrais également
par anticipation peut-être remercier
l'Assemblée nationale qui a aussi
accepté sur le principe un dialogue en
amont avec notre assemblée afin que ce
projet loi puisse aboutir le plus
rapidement possible en fin je voudrais
remercier particulièrement les
administrateurs du Sénat qui devait
partir en vacances vendredi et qui ont
prolongé leur travail
après l'année compliquée et lourde que
nous avons connu je pense que nous
pouvons les applaudir en tout cas moi je
les remercie
[Applaudissements]
et si vous me le permettez madame la
Présidente je remercie tous les
sénateurs qui sont là aujourd'hui et qui
par définition
prennent le risque de voir l'assemblée
nous faire revenir vendredi mais
espérons tous ensemble que ce ne sera
pas le cas la parole est maintenant au
président Vincent Delahaye rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des finances
pour 5 minutes
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est vrai
que vous nous présentez monsieur le
ministre un projet de loi urgence
reconstruction vous l'avez dit il va
falloir aussi et nous l'attendons
impatiemment à avoir un texte qui traite
les causes de ses émeutes et
nous aurons plaisir à pouvoir discuter
de ce texte le plus rapidement possible
je voudrais aussi ici même rendre
hommage
dans le département de l'Essonne mais
aussi dans tous les départements touchés
à tous ces maires tous ces élus tous ces
ce personnel municipal c'est bénévole
aussi qui se sont mobilisés plusieurs
nuits de suite pour essayer de limiter
les dégâts de ses émeutes alors la
commission des finances c'est saisie
pour avis avec une délégation au fond
sur son article 3
pour faciliter le lancement des travaux
de réparation cet article prévoit une
série de mesures dérogatoires aux droits
communs du financement des
investissements locaux
comme les deux autres il prend la forme
d'une habilitation du gouvernement
allégérée par ordonnance dans un délai
de trois mois
un projet de loi de ratification de
l'ordonnance devra ensuite être déposé
dans les trois mois qui suivent sa
publication
pour financer les opérations de
réparation il convient de rappeler que
les collectivités bénéficieront d'une
part d'indemnités au titre de
l'engagement de la responsabilité sans
faute de l'État qui est civilement
responsable des dégâts et dommages
résultant des crimes et délits commis à
l'occasion de manifestations qui
dégénèrent et d'autre part des prises en
charge par les assureurs au moins pour
les collectivités qui ont souscrit les
contrats d'assurance
trois mesures sont ainsi proposées en
premier lieu le gouvernement se
rétablitait à déroger au régime de droit
commun du versement du Fonds de
compensation pour la TVA le FCTVA en
l'état du droit les collectivités
perçoivent les attributions au titre de
ce fond en N + 2 ou dans certains cas en
N+1 par rapport à l'exécution des
dépenses
exposer des motifs précise que
l'habilitation permettra ainsi un
versement anticipé du FCTVA dès l'année
N pour les travaux de réparation entre
prix pour les collectivités à la suite
des dégradations intervenues entre le 27
juin et le 5 juillet 2023 non seulement
cette mesure est pleinement justifiée
monsieur le ministre mais je considère
même à titre personnel qu'elle devrait
constituer le fonctionnement normal du
FCTVA
dès lors que son bénéfice constitue un
droit pour les collectivités
territoriales il n'y a pas de raison que
l'État préserve 26 sa propre trésorerie
au détriment de celle des collectivités
par ailleurs cet outil ne serait être
considéré à lui seul comme une réponse
suffisante
puisqu’un certain nombre de dépenses
engagés par les collectivités pour
procéder aux réparations ne sont pas
éligibles au FCTVA
en deuxième lieu l'article habilite le
gouvernement a dérogé à la règle
imposant une participation minimale des
collectivités au financement de leurs
projets d'investissement
dans le droit commun cette part est
fixée à 20% de l'ensemble de des
financements apportés par les personnes
faits publiques il en résulterait selon
l'exposé des motifs que les
collectivités pourraient bénéficier de
subventions allant jusqu'à 100% du coût
des travaux
en parallèle de cette mesure législative
une instruction ministérielle d'ores et
déjà prévu
a déjà
d'ores et déjà prévu la création d'un
fond dédié au sein de la mission
budgétaire relation avec les
collectivités territoriales pour le
soutien à la reconstruction
cependant la traduction budgétaire du
dispositif reste encore flou à ce jour
et l'administration n'a pas été en
mesure de me fournir d'évaluation de son
cou à ce stade
il serait donc souhaitable que le
gouvernement eugarre à la confiance que
nous lui accordons en lui donnant cette
habilitation communique dès que possible
au Parlement des précisions sur le
montant de l'enveloppe sur ces modalités
de financement et le caserne sur la
nécessité d'ouvrir des crédits
supplémentaires en loi de finances
rectificative en fin de gestion
en troisième et dernier lieu
l'ordonnance permettrait de déroger à la
règle de plafonnement des fonds de
concours pouvant être versés au sein des
intercommunalités dans les attributions
ne peuvent aujourd'hui excéder la part
du financement assuré hors subventions
par le bénéficiaire du fond de concours
cette mesure permettrait de donner
davantage de souplesse aux collectivités
pour le financement des travaux de
réparation
son impact budgétaire est quant à lui
neutre pour l'État puisqu'il n'est
question que de flux financier interne
au bloc communal
enfin Monsieur le Ministre la méthode de
l'habilitation appelle naturellement une
certaine vigilance de notre part
au cas présent elle est proposée par le
gouvernement au regard du caractère à la
fois urgent technique et je le crois
consensuel des mesures envisagées pour
faciliter l'engagement rapide par les
collectivités des travaux nécessaires à
la réparation des dégâts causés par les
émeutes
la commission des finances vous propose
donc d'en prendre acte monsieur le
ministre et d'adopter cet article sans
modification je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président
la parole est maintenant Madame
Catherine difolco rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des lois pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre madame
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
la commission des lois a été saisie de
l'article 2 du projet de loi qui
habilite le gouvernement à légiférer par
ordonnance afin de permettre aux
acheteurs publics de déroger à certaines
règles de la commande publique pour
faciliter la réflexion ou la
reconstruction des bâtiments publics
dégradés lors des récentes violences
urbaines lorsque des bâtiments publics
sont attaqués qu'il s'agissent d'une
mairie Agora de la démocratie locale ou
de ceux qui délivrent des services
quotidiens à la population ce sont la
République et le vivre ensemble qui sont
attaqués nous ne pouvions donc rester
sans réponse le reconstruction rapide
autant que nécessaire
pour la continuité du service public que
pour symboliser la reprise de l'ordre
républicain face à ces violences que
nous condamnons et par conséquent un
objectif que la Commission a soutenue en
adoptant l'article 2 ces violences
inadmissibles dans leur expression on
ciblait de nombreuses personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
pompier force de l'ordre ou encore élus
locaux les bâtiments publics ont
également payé un lourd tribu lors de
ses actions il représente 30% des
bâtiments endommagés au total plus de
750 bâtiments publics nécessitent des
travaux de réflexion ou de
reconstruction parmi ceux-ci les
bâtiments les plus emblématiques des
institutions républicaines locales ont
fait l'objet de dégradation
273 bâtiments des forces de l'ordre 168
écoles 105 mairies ont été détériorées
au lendemain de ses émeutes ce triste
bilan appelle notre mobilisation
collective pour conduire dans l'urgence
un chantier national de reconstruction
relevez ce défi à peine un cadre
juridique d'exception de Natura accéléré
au maximum la conduite des travaux dans
cette perspective et face au risque
juridique que constituerait l'initiation
de travaux d'urgence sur le fondement
des seuls desrogations déjà permises par
le droit de la commande publique
l'article 2 vise à garantir aux
acheteurs publics une assise juridique
sur et à les inciter à lancer
promptement les travaux nécessaires ces
nouvelles dérogations temporaires et
limitée au seul bâtiment public
endommagés lors de ses émeutes
permettrait aux acheteurs publics de
passer des marchés publics sans
publicité mais avec mise en concurrence
pour des travaux dont le montant serait
inférieur à un seuil défini dans
l'ordonnance
les premières pistes du gouvernement
évoquaient un seuil d'un million d'euros
soit un fort rehaussement par rapport au
seuil de droit commun de 100.000 euros
il permettrait également de ne pas
alotir les marchés et enfin de conclure
plus facilement des marchés globaux le
gain de temps estimé de la dégrogation
au principe de publicité s'élève pour
l'acheteur public à quatre semaines en
permettant de ne passer qu'un seul
marché la conclusion d'un marché global
entraînerait quant à elle un gain
approximatif de quatre mois
les dérogations que nous propose le
gouvernement nous paraissent justifier
et proportionnés pour atteindre
l'objectif de rétablissement des
services publics dans les communes
concernées dans une démarche
constructive la Commission a adoptée en
amendement sur cet articlearifiant
l'étendue du périmètre de ces
dérogations en mentionnant les acheteurs
soumis au code de la commande publique
afin notamment de lever une ambiguïté
résultant du texte initial et d'inclure
les bailleurs sociaux
notre soutien ce texte n'est cependant
pas un chèque en blanc à ce titre nous
avons émis trois réserves monsieur le
ministre en premier lieu le seuil d'un
million d'euros évoqué par le
gouvernement en dessous duquel les
acheteurs publics pourront déroger aux
principes de publicité ne nous semble
pas à la hauteur des enjeux de
reconstruction des bâtiments publics
nous souhaiterions savoir nous
souhaiterions que le gouvernement
réévalue ce seuil en prenant en
considération les bourrasins réels
exprimées par les collectivités
publiques afin de que ce régime
exceptionnel soit plus aisément
mobilisable par les auteurs les
acheteurs publics en effet il existe une
marge de manœuvre significative puisque
la réglementation européenne autorise
les dérogations jusqu'à 5,3 millions
d'euros c'est pourquoi la Commission a
adopté un amendement modifiant
l'intitulé du projet de loi afin que
celui-ci mentionne les travaux de
réfection des bâtiments endommagés
illustrant ainsi sa portée réelle
monsieur le ministre nous nous sommes en
outre interrogés sur l'étendue de
l'amendement numéro 5 vous avez présenté
que nous avons examiné ce matin alors
que suite à une demande les services du
ministère nous ont infirmé à trois
reprises que les travaux de voirie
publique ne font pas partie des
équipements publics alors l'exposé des
motifs de cette amendement les
mentionnent explicitement nous attendons
par conséquent monsieur le ministre des
précisions de votre part quant au
périmètre précis de l'ordonnance est-ce
que la voirie est incluse est-ce que les
lampadaires sont inclus est-ce que la
vidéoprotection est incluse etc merci
monsieur le ministre pour toutes ces
précisions enfin nous regrettons à
l'instar du Conseil d'État que le
gouvernement ne soit pas allé au bout de
la démarche d'urgence qui aurait
consisté à inscrire dans le projet de
loi le dispositif dérogatoire plutôt de
recourir à une ordonnance en effet le
gain estimé pour la par la dérogation au
principe de publicité de quatre semaines
soit un temps un temps bien inférieur au
délai de deux mois demandés par le
gouvernement pour publier l'ordonnance à
tout le moins il nous semble important
que l'ordonnance soit soumise à l'examen
du Conseil des ministres dans les
meilleurs délais si possible même avant
la pose estivale afin que les procédures
de passation des marchés puissent être
engagés rapidement merci monsieur le
Président j'ai juste eu un mot de
conclusion j'espère monsieur le ministre
vous serez en mesure de vous engager
devant la représentation nationale sur
ce point qui permettrait de répondre à
une très forte attente des mers je vous
remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine pour le beau-père des pays pour
6 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
décidément
urgence et résilience sont désormais les
impératifs de l'action publique mais
parlementaire gouvernement tous nous
avons dû agir vite et fort face à la
succession des crises qui n'ont
d'ailleurs souvent pas épargnés nos
voisins ni le monde je pense à la crise
sanitaire je pense aux crises écologique
comme aux émeutes qui ne sont pas la
panage de la France en témoigne les
violents émeutes qui avaient touché en
2011 le Royaume-Uni à la suite là aussi
de la mort d'un jeune homme ou bien
encore l'Allemagne âge Stuttgart en juin
2020 nous voici donc réunis pour prendre
les mesures urgentes qui s'imposent
après les graves événements qui ont
touché plusieurs centaines de communes
du Pays les balafrans de stigmates et
qui même un jour disparu laisseront des
traces profondes dans les esprits dans
l'Yonne comme ailleurs nous n'avons pas
été épargnés à Sens à Joigny à Migennes
à Saint-Florentin à Auxerre chez nous
comme partout ailleurs nos compatriotes
ont été choqués sidérés par le
déferlement de cette violence contre les
figures d'autorité de notre pays qui ont
été attaqués monsieur le ministre et
vocalé chiffres j'ai une pensée
particulière naturellement pour Vincent
Jean Brun pour sa famille pour d'autres
maires pris comme cible je pense à
Stéphanie vanove maire de Pontoise une
violence qui s'est traduite par le
pillage de magasin de commerce faisant
dire d'ailleurs à Sylvain Tesson que
nous étions en présence des émeutes de
l'iPhone car lorsque la consommation est
érigée en nouvelle religion dans les
comportements et bien forcément on voit
que désormais ce qui est plus important
c'est paraître ce n'est pas être je
pille donc je suis semble dire ces
jeunes qui nous narguent à coup d'émoji
sur les réseaux sociaux des cartes
revient ils sont devenus fous nous avons
assisté un puissant au pillage de la
ville me confier le maire de sens paul
Antoine de Carville une de ces nuits là
une violence aveugle et gratuite enfin
gratuite pas tout à fait car justement
l'addition sera lourde et à ce moment je
veux rendre hommage à l'action des
forces de sécurité police nationale
gendarmerie pompier sans oublier les
policiers municipaux qui ont parfois été
en première ligne et souvent dans des
rapports de force qui n'auraient pas
favorables à quelques dizaines contre
plusieurs centaines
aujourd'hui lors des revenus c'est
heureux et l'heure est à la
reconstruction c'est l'objet de ce
projet de loi d'habitation monsieur le
ministre il s'agit en urgence de donner
les moyens aux élus locaux de
reconstruire et de réparer le plus
rapidement possible vous proposez trois
habilitations pour légiférer par voie
d'ordonnance et le contexte le justifie
dès lors que la rapidité sera au
rendez-vous sans atteindre la butée des
deux ou trois mois selon les articles et
je me réjouis d'ailleurs que la
commission des affaires économiques est
adopté ce texte dans un large consensus
madame la Présidente le tout n'a qu'un
seul objectif reconstruire vite et bien
alors vite et bien ça signifie déroger
au droit en vigueur pour autoriser la
reconstruction à l'identique ça signifie
permettre l'engagement des opérations
des travaux prélimitaires dès le dépôt
de la demande d'urbanisme c'est aussi se
risquer qui était mis en place pour
regarder peut-être que l'avenir ça
puisse servir de façon plus systématique
vite et bien c'est également simplifier
les conditions de recours au marché
globaux c'est limiter la lotissement
vite et bien surtout en étant
financièrement accompagné c'est l'objet
de l'article 3 avec cette dérogation à
l'obligation de participation minimale
de 20% avec le des fonds de concours
avec le versement anticipé du FCTVA tout
cela Monsieur le Ministre et bienvenue
et permettez-moi néanmoins d'appeler
votre attention sur quelques sujets
Catherine difolco l'a fait à l'instant
la voirie le remplacement des caméras de
vidéo surveillance il me semble que
l'amendement que vous déposez ce matin
va dans ce sens d'un élargissement et
cette heureux il y a des attentes et
puis des attentes aussi peut-être
d'outils pour faire des avances de
liquidité pour des communes parce que
lorsque des projets sont partis en fumée
et que c'est des projets qui n'étaient
pas encore aboutis il y a là des besoins
je pense à sens dont le projet de centre
social a été détruit voilà pour la
reconstruction matérielle et vous nous
trouverez monsieur le ministre
résolument à vos côtés pour voter les
dispositions de ce texte mais nous avons
devant nous un autre chantier
considérable celui de la reconstruction
républicaine et morale si je puis dire
comment faire pour qu'il n'y ait plus
des France qui se regardent en chien de
faïence parce que vivre ensemble ça se
décrète pas ça se construit au quotidien
souvenez-vous Renan la nation qui est ce
plébiscite de tous les jours et donc il
nous faut à nouveau des creusets qui le
sentiment d'appartenance nationale et je
crois qu'il est il est temps oui de
passer au SMU en format XXL en
généralisant c'est une voix pour
remédier à l'anomie à la désaffiliation
qui guette et puis tout simplement il
faut l'ordre et le progrès pour faire
notre une autre devise nationale ordre
bien sûr car aucun territoire ne
serait-ce soustraire à l'ordre
républicain la République elle ne doit
pas tolérer de ZAD de zones à détruire
ni de s ZND de zone de non-droit ordre
puisque 40% des interpellés le ministre
de l'Intérieur le disait avait déjà un
casier judiciaire où était inscrit au
fichier était agi ne laissons pas
quelques dizaines de milliers de
fauteurs de troubles mettre à mal
l'unité de la nation et désespéré cette
majorité silencieuse que vous évoquiez
progrès également car aucun territoire
ne serait être considéré comme oublier
abandonné ou pire encore perdu et ne
posant pas les territoires c'est valable
pour le rural comme pour le ruban comme
l'urbain et les quartiers je pense aux
maisons France service je pense au
retour des services publics dans les
territoires je pense
à des dotations que vous avez
significativement augmenté pour
accompagner les territoires alors
Monsieur le Ministre on le voit les
sujets posés par les jours que nous
avons vécu ne sont pas épuisés par le
débat d'aujourd'hui mais ce débat est
cette loi sont un préalable
indispensable raison pour laquelle le
groupe RDPI à l'unisson de bien des
bancs on l'a vu hier en commission des
affaires économiques sera à vos côtés
votre à ce projet de d'habitation je
vous remercie chers collègues
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Christian Redon
sarrazzi pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission aux affaires
économiques monsieur le rapporteur les
émeutes qui ont eu lieu entre le 27 juin
et le 5 juillet à la suite de la mort du
jeune Naël ont surpris par la violence
et l'ampleur des dégâts qu'ils ont
entraînés elles ont impacté en
Île-de-France dans les métropoles et
dans les Territoires jusque-là épargner
près de 500 communes entraîner la
dégradation voir la destruction de plus
de 800 bâtiments publics mairie école
bibliothèque ou poste de police ce qui a
rompu la continuité du service public
les commerces n'ont pas été épargnés et
ont parfois subi des pillages le présent
projet de loi d'urgence formule en trois
articles la réponse du gouvernement face
à ces événements à savoir une demande
d'habilitation légiférée par ordonnance
afin de créer un cas juridique un cadre
juridique d'exception notamment en
matière de droit de l'urbanisme et de la
construction
de nombreuses communes et villes font
désormais face à l'impériose nécessité
de rouvrir centre aéré base de loisirs
pour accueillir les enfants cet été de
réhabiliter leurs écoles pour les
accueillir à dès la rentrée septembre
d'assurer la continuité de certains
services publics dans les bâtiments ont
été touchés pour autant si les
intentions sont louables ce texte en
comportement et une faiblesse criante
qui est son imprécision tant sur le
périmètre des actions pour lesquelles le
gouvernement demande de légiférer par
ordonnance que sur les aspects
financiers mais aussi avec d'autres
inconnus si le gouvernement a évoqué la
possibilité de reconstruire en
améliorant la performance
environnementale la sécurité et
l'accessibilité des bâtiments par
rapport à l'état antérieur celle-ci
n'est pas clairement précisée dans le
texte le texte prévoit que la
reconstruction puisse se faire
nonobstant toute disposition de droits y
compris lorsqu’un document d'urbanisme
applicable en dispose autrement nous
n'avons pas de garanti en termes de
protection du patrimoine ou de la
participation du public en ce qui
concerne les installations provisoires
pour permettre l'accueil du public ou la
continuité des services publics
entre-ront-elles monsieur le ministre
dans le champ des ordonnances aucune
précision non plus sur l'encadrement de
la durée de mise en oeuvre des mesures
d'urgence toutefois tout au plus
évoquant un délai limité enfin le délai
annoncé le 2 à 3 semaines pour publier
les ordonnances nous paraît totalement
contradictoires avec le discours de
gouvernement sur le caractère d'urgence
nous en demanderons donc par voie
d'amendement une publication plus rapide
bâti dans l'urgence ce texte n'est de
toute façon pas le bon véhicule
législatif permettant de fournir les
financements nécessaires en cas de
dépenses accidentelle ou liée à des
circonstances exceptionnelles mais nous
ne pourrons pas nous exonérer de voter
en sa faveur car il est malgré tout
nécessaire pour rassurer les élus et nos
concitoyens pour autant ces faiblesses
exigent un contrôle parlementaire
rigoureux à la fois pour accélérer les
travaux et pour les encadrer afin
d'éviter les abus enfin plus largement
nous ne pouvons pas nous empêcher de
souligner que ce texte exclusivement
technique ne résoudra pas le problème de
fond la destruction la plus préoccupante
étant celle de notre cohésion sociale
les émeutes sont revenus ne sauraient
être qualifiées de manière réductrice
d'urbaine comme ce fut le cas par
exemple en 2005 en effet aucun
territoire épargner sur 553 communes
touchées 169 ne sont pas en politique de
la ville c'est la triste illustration
d'un mal-être 1 qui s'aggrave d'une
décollection de plus en plus évidente
entre l'État et la population d'un fossé
devenu béant entre certaines classes
sociales et entre Français monsieur le
ministre les mobilisations sociales qui
se succèdent inlassablement devrait vous
interroger nous n'en serions pas là
aujourd'hui si l'État avait apporté des
réponses concrètes ou des classements
d'une large partie de la population
ghettoïsée géographiquement et
socialement depuis au moins les
dernières de 2005 si ce n'est depuis
plus de 30 ans les élus et les
associations comme les familles
dénoncent la disparition progressive de
la police de proximité les questions
systémiques de discrimination et de
racisme au sein des forces de police
n'ont jamais été réglées et très peu
interrogés depuis 1990 les politiques de
la ville successives ont représenter 90
milliards d'euros d'investissement de la
part de l'État c'est le montant annuel
des exonérations des cotisations
sociales pour les entreprises et ce
n'est rien comparé au financement engagé
depuis 2020 pour faire face à la
pandémie faut-il dès lors étonné du
résultat les politiques de la ville
n'ont jamais réglé l'absence de mixité
sociale dans les quartiers licencibles
alors que c'est un des problèmes
fondamentaux qui explique entre autres
l'exclusivité du contexte actuel
l'urgence c'est d'interroger leur
postulat créer une nouvelle urbanité
arrêtez le culte du zonage un étiquetage
qui finit qui fait fuir les populations
plus qu'il ne les attire mais la réponse
financière elle seule ne réglera pas
tout il faut apporter des réponses
éducatives familiales sociales à la
situation la véritable urgence mes chers
collègues et pour l'état de réagir à la
hauteur des enjeux pour éviter que ces
expressions de violence se multiplient
pour éviter la fragmentation continue de
notre société jusqu'à un point de
non-retours nous avons posé un
diagnostic et nous formulons
inlassablement des propositions
concrètes pour y remédier renforcer la
protection des élus locaux toujours en
première ligne renforcer les moyens des
collèges des lycées dans les conditions
d'enseignement ne font que se dégrader
depuis 5 ans accompagner les familles
monoparentales organiser un comité
interministériel des villes avec des
propositions concrètes et transversales
enfin
oser de traiter la question sécuritaire
en envisageant des réformes profondes et
le retour d'une véritable police du
quotidien sur le territoire
merci
c'est chers collègues
la parole est maintenant monsieur Fabien
gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 27 juin
dernier Nanterre un policier a tué un
jeune de 17 ans je tiens à redire
l'émotion qui est la note pour Maël et
l'Isère constance de sa mort 40 ans
après les manguettes 18 ans après il y a
des Bouna la justice doit être au
rendez-vous pour Noël l'émotion légitime
qui a suscité ce drame c'est rapidement
muet en une colère vive une colère qui a
détruit des biens publics et des biens
privés et celles et ceux qui se
trouvaient déjà pénalisés par des
services publics défaillants ou absents
faute de moyens financiers humains
souffriront davantage encore de ces
dégradations que nous avons condamnés
c'est donc pour elle et la double peine
les biens publics qui ont été dégradés
doivent être reconstruits au plus vite
c'est le sens du texte que nous
examinons ici qui crée des dérogations
en fin d'accélérer les procédures
d'urbanisme et les marchés publics au vu
de l'urgence nous partageons cette
nécessité exceptionnel néanmoins ce
texte n'est pas sans susciter des
interrogations tout y sont possible mais
rien n'y est sûr ni que des projets de
reconstruction aboutiront ni que
l'argent sera ajouté afin que l'État les
finances une fois encore il nous faudra
attendre les ordonnances pour connaître
la concrétisation des dispositifs alors
qu'un projet de loi des finances
rectificatives plus transparent et
respectueux du Parlement aurait été
mieux indiqué cela étant nous nous
rejoignons sur cet objectif il faut
reconstruire vite la présence des
services publics sur l'ensemble du
territoire et les galaxies à ceux-ci est
l'un des piliers de notre République la
République convoquait ces derniers jours
dans beaucoup de discours dans des arcs
qui inclut ceux qui l'ont toujours
combattu mais exclus ce dont l'histoire
s'inscrit dans sa défense un
bouleversement des valeurs qui
brouillent le sens nous pensons que la
République doit s'incarner
en premier lieu pour la présence des
services publics cependant la
reconstruction des bâtiments n'est qu'un
aspect du problème car s'il faut
reconstruire vite il faut surtout
rebâtir urgemment la cohésion et la
justice sociale et j'irai même jusqu'à
dire notre République d'abord il faut
mettre en débat le lien entre la police
et une partie de la population les
classes populaires notamment qui
subissent les violences policières qui
ne peuvent plus être niés celle dont le
premier syndicat de police de France dit
que ce sont des nuisibles et appelle à
la guerre civile dans un silence
assourdissant je vous le dis monsieur le
ministre de votre gouvernement
inacceptable dans un état de droit
ensuite il faut admettre que les
quartiers populaires cumulent les
difficultés les services publics qui
sont moins présent qu'ailleurs il ne
s'agit pas de se plaindre ni de vouloir
davantage que les autres il s'agit d'une
soif d'égalité républicaine d'autant que
contrairement à une idée répandue par
l'extrême droite et ses affidés il n'y a
pas seulement 25% de gens qui payent
l'impôt dans les quartiers mes chers
collègues je vous livre un scoop en
France tout le monde paye l'impôt à tout
le monde un point juste puisqu'il est
d'antique pour tous smicard comme
millionnaire c'est la TVA donc dans les
banlieues nous avons des citoyens qui
paient l'impôt au même titre que les
autres mais sans bénéficier des mêmes
services il n'y a pas comme dans un
tonneau des Danaïdes des milliards qui
seraient dépensés pour les banlieues au
contraire il y a moins il y a des
transports qui dysfonctionnent j'en sais
quelque chose étant usagé du RER B il y
a des professeurs absents qui ne sont
pas ou peu remplacés ce qui est occasion
la perte de l'équivalent d'une année
scolaire pour un élève de la
Seine-Saint-Denis par exemple la justice
débordée y est rendu trois fois plus
lentement qu'ailleurs et le taux de
pauvreté et trois fois plus élevé dans
les quartiers populaires que dans le
reste du pays et on peut ajouter
l'emploi le logement l'accès à la santé
tant d'autres choses et à ces membres
qui est ces difficultés viennent
s'ajouter un discours de stigmatisation
d'exclusion et de division or pour des
responsables politiques diviser les
citoyens et les opposés sur la base de
discrimination c'est fragmenter la
République ce à quoi nous devons nous
employer c'est à retisser du lien plutôt
qu'à diviser comme ne cesse de le faire
l'extrême droite et ses alliés qui ne
réfléchissent pas plus loin que leur
désir d'exclusion je le dis fermement
ici il n'y a pas des catégories de
français il n'y a pas de français
comment pas de français de nationalité
faciale ou encore de papiers il y a le
peuple français et il y a la République
française c'est tout il en va de même
pour nos territoires banlieues
territoires ruraux et ultramarins tous
subissent en réalité l'assèchement des
services publics les privatisations et
les politiques libérales pour finir
plutôt que nous nous diviser
rassemblons-nous pour ceux qui sont en
zone blanche de la République un
issons-nous pour donner à tous nos élus
qui en ont assez d'exercer leur mandat
avec trois bouts de ficelle et deux
sparadraps les moyens pour répondre aux
besoins la population aujourd'hui nous
votons ce texte et demain nous
continuerons le combat pour que la
République démocratique sociale laïque
et féministe ne soient plus seulement
des mots mais s'applique partout sans
exclusion surtout le territoire merci
chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Madame
Françoise Ferrat pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du Sénat
monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs le rapporteur mes chers
collègues le décès d'un jeune est
toujours un drame pourtant une excuse en
rien le défaire le monde est violence
les pillages les actes délictuelles et
criminels que ce drame a suscité la
justice devra faire toute la lumière sur
les circonstances de ce décès nous
concitoyens n'ont pas à payer le prix de
la bêtise agressive d'une minorité
violente c'est délinquant au prix
prétexte de ce drame pour mettre un sac
d'écartier et faire acte de violence sur
les forces de sécurité les élus ou les
biens publics et privés il s'attaque à
la Concorde républicaine et détruisent
ce que nous avons tant de temps à bâtir
avec mes collègues du groupe
unocentrisme nous condamnons vivement
les agissements de ses voyous et
souhaitons dire toute notre soutien à
l'ensemble des sinistrés aux enfants qui
voient leur école détruite et aux
citoyens et conseillers municipaux des
105 mairies dégradées car ces violences
se sont plus de 600 millions d'euros de
dégâts en 4 jours des écoles endommagées
et près de 850 bâtiments publics
dégradés ou incendiés
c'est cassures détruisent leur propre
service public leur propre commerce et
ruines le quotidien de leur famille et
de leurs voisins notre groupe a fait et
continuera à faire des propositions pour
enrayer ces flots de violence et réussir
la politique de la ville il nous faudra
consolider notre politique familiale le
soutien à la parentalité et précisément
la responsabilité des parents vis-à-vis
des agissements et de l'éducation de
leurs enfants
en plus d'une réponse pénale et
sécuritaire forte le gouvernement se
devrait de prendre toute sa part dans la
reconstruction et dans le soutien au
sinistre ce texte est donc une nécessité
nous devons agir rapidement afin que les
collectivités puissent reconstruire des
infrastructures touchées à ce titre la
dérogation à certaines règles de droit
commun en matière de commande publique
et de droits de l'urbanisme et salutaire
les interrogations restent tenues en
moins nombreuses les pistes de soutien
financier au collectivités sont
esquissés mais en aucun cas précisé de
plus nous aurions souhaité plus de
transparence et de co-construction pour
les ordonnances
celles-ci doivent être prises avec un
savant équilibre entre précautions et
pragmatisme le gouvernement doit agir
avec prudence et avec force
cette simplicité et cette réactivité
devrait à l'avenir inspirer l'État pour
faciliter la vie de nos élus et libérer
de quelques contraintes administratives
enfin ce projet de loi doit permettre de
faire des conséquences dramatiques de
ses émeutes une opportunité unique pour
massifier la rénovation énergétique et
investir afin de passer un cap
supplémentaire en la matière
c'est le sens de l'amendement que
j'avais initialement déposé afin de ne
pas oublier le nécessaire transition
écologique énergétique qui sera
primordial surtout dans un nombre de ces
quartiers prioritaires pour lesquels la
précarité énergétique est un facteur
aggravant madame la rapporteur a pris en
compte cette demande et j'en suis
satisfait
les investissements performants en
matière d'économie d'énergie et de
transition écologique
permettront aux collectivités locales et
entreprises de s'y retrouver à terme
économiquement face à la flambée des
prix des énergies et de résilience
écologique mes chers collègues le groupe
unocentriste votera pour ce texte mais
nous ne devons pas laisser nos élus au
bord de la route il faut redéfinir notre
socle républicain il nous faut tirer les
enseignements de cette crise je vous
remercie
merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Daniel salmon pour
le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre se rapporteur chers collègues
la drame de la mort de Naël le 27 juin
tué par un policier à Nanterre a suscité
l'émotion de toute la nation puis une
colère immense à submergé le pays cette
colère et ses ressorts profonds sont
présents de manière chronique ils n'ont
toujours pas été clairement analysés et
donc compris alors que c'est une des
conditions pour apporter des réponses et
pour que cette situation ne se
reproduise plus une partie d'expression
de cette colère c'est cristallisée dans
la casse le pillage la violence et nous
sommes pris de vertige face à cette
autodestruction bien sûr rien ne peut
justifier cette violence les
intimidations les agressions la
destruction de commerce et de bâtiments
publics les écologistes sont tout de
suite condamnées ces modes d'action
violents ils ont condamné à fermeté les
attaques incalifiables qu'on subit
notamment les élus de la République à
nouveau en première ligne mais rappelons
que les forces de l'ordre malgré des
missions de plus en plus difficiles se
doivent d'avoir des pratiques
exemplaires dans chacun de leurs actes
du quotidien car l'exemple arrêté est le
meilleur empereur de la démocratie
la violence légitime ne doit en aucun
cas sombrer dans la violence injustifiée
alors que les émeutes urbaines sont
calmées pour le moment tout le monde est
d'accord sur la nécessité de
reconstruire et vite une école un centre
de loisirs une salle des fêtes un
service d'état civils constituent des
services essentiels les élus des
communes touchées par ses émeutes
attendent des assouplissements et
l'accélération de procédures afin
d'engager au plus vite les chantiers de
rénovation ou de reconstruction
précisons dans un premier temps que nous
déplorons fortement la volonté du
gouvernement de faire passer ses
dispositifs à travers une loi
d'habilitation alors qu'elle n'apporte
pas de gain de temps et contrat encore
une fois les parlementaires dans le
droit d'amendement
si les délais de procédure en matière de
manie c'est de publicité des marchés
publics seront raccourcis la question de
la disponibilité des matériaux et des
entreprises restent entières nous posons
également quelques alertes monsieur le
ministre la qualité du bâti reconstruit
est primordial reconstruire à
l'identique serait préjudiciable si les
exigences de performance
environnementale notamment thermique
mais aussi de fonctionnalités ne sont
pas réinterroger attention de ne pas
confondre vitesse et précipitations par
ailleurs le texte tente à déroger aux
règles de passation et de dévolution des
marchés publics si nous entendons la
nécessité de cette mesure il est
important que l'État assure un contrôle
strict afin d'éviter les dérives et
prévenir d'éventuelles conflits
d'intérêts au final nous l'avons dit ce
texte est une réponse partielle et court
thermiste elle est certes nécessaire et
attendue par les élus locaux c'est
pourquoi nous l'avons mais elle ne
constitue en rien un début d'analyse des
causes structurelles des événements qui
permettraient de fixer un cap là-dessus
il n'y a aucune réponse ni aucune
méthode de la part du président de la
République ni du gouvernement certes
depuis 2005 la politique de la ville a
apporté quelques réponses mais les
actions se sont concentrées sur de la
rénovation urbaine je pense par exemple
au nouveau programme de renouvellement
urbain lancé en 2014 mais le plus
souvent ces rénovations ont été menées
sans les habitants voire leur ont été
imposées et la question de
l'accompagnement social a été mis de
côté
enfin en France ce qui est profondément
ancré c'est que l'on pense que l'on va
régler le social par le spatial la
rénovation a permis de changer le visage
de nombreux quartiers mais sur l'école
sur les discriminations sur l'accès à
l'emploi sur le rapport à la police sur
les concentrations d'inégalités
d'injustice de frustration et d'échecs
la relégation les premiersmatiques
restent entière la sociologue urbaniste
Marie-Hélène baquet autrise un rapport
en 2013 sur la politique de la ville
souligne la perte de sa substance
sociale cette dernière a été
bureaucratisée et les professionnels et
associations qui contribuent sont
aujourd'hui largement épuisées par les
logiques de concurrence et d'appel
d'offres à quand est grand élan des
services publics dans les quartiers
populaires à quand la co-construction
avec les habitants des politiques de
transformation sociale à Caen une
réforme profonde de l'institution
policière afin qu'elle retrouve un
ancrage local et un rôle de gardien de
la paix
à partir de ce quartier se pose des
questions centrales pour la société
française celle de l'égalité de la
démocratie celle de la gestion de la
crise climatique qui s'y fera sentir
plus fortement qu'ailleurs et celle de
notre héritage coloniale pour toutes les
embrasser il faut de la volonté et du
courage politique nous les attendons
merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant au président Jean-Claude
Roquier pour le groupe RDS pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président de séance madame
monsieur le ministre même la présidente
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs
de police aurait pu se dérouler qui ont
un autre et a conduit au décès dans les
circonstances dramatiques de jeune homme
17 ans à Nanterre l'émotion du moment
est là c'était rapidement débordé par
plusieurs lignes de violence urbaine de
dégradation et de pillages ça rapport
direct qui est hors de proportions avec
le fait initial nous sommes
malheureusement comment une actualité
chasse l'autre et qu'un fait divers ou
un événement est vite remplacé par un
autre qui fait les gros titres quelques
jours plus tard les tous n'ont pas les
conséquences en termes d'audience entre
tes lois facilité par les moyens que les
réseaux sociaux et l'information en
continu une semaine après événement
déclencheur des dégâts matériels étaient
presque comparable à se engendrer par la
catastrophe naturelle le gouvernement a
d'abord estimé les montants quelques 300
millions d'euros Déjà un record par
rapport à ces modes et au moment des
gilets jaunes les compagnies assurances
ont réévalués la semaine dernière secoue
à 650 millions d'euros et donc on dit
que le bilan matériel va continuer
s’alourdir dans les prochains jours je
reviens sur la stupidation Collective
constatée face à cette éruption
soudainement avec disons-le quelque peu
crapuleuses lorsqu'il s'agit de piller
des boutiques d'électronique des
vêtements de chaussures les acteurs du
terrain nous diront sans doute que le
risque était prévisible mais il devient
chaque jour plus évident que nous avons
manqué depuis maintenant plusieurs
décennies d'importants objectifs en
matière d'éducation d'intégration de
vivre ensemble de fait de la France
voici l'indicateurs de criminalité et
elle est un camp régulièrement augmenté
cette semaine dernière mon collègue qui
rigole avait attiré l'attention du
gouvernement lors des question
d'actualité sur l'inquiétante
banalisation des violences quotidiennes
en particulier en milieu scolaire et
l'urgence irrémédié je rappellerai aussi
une nouvelle fois les travaux de mon
collègue Henri Caval sur l'engagement et
la culture citoyenne chez les jeunes un
axe approfondir on ne peut que regretter
le manque d'attention accordée en 2008 à
la remise du dernier plan Borlo qui est
précolisé en particulier les concentrer
les efforts sur l'éducation et le lien
social dans les quartiers difficiles si
mon groupe votera ses habitations compte
tenu du caractère d'urgence de la
situation nous continuerons nous
interroger sur la réponse à donner à
plus long terme comment résoudre si les
problèmes de violence urbaine est plus
généralement des civilités petit ou
grande qui fragilise notre société et
dans les premières victimes sont
précisément les habitants de ces
quartiers comment lutter contre le
sentiment d'abandon et de relégation
répandue en milieu urbain mais aussi en
mer rural malgré les milliards d'euros
investissent chaque année dans la
politique de la ville et les dispositifs
différents de solidarité
comment faire améliorer les relations
entre les forces de l'ordre et la
population qui apparaissent toujours
fortement dégradée je n'oublie pas bien
sûr la protection des élus sur laquelle
travaille beaucoup le Sénat ainsi que le
RDSE et Nathalie Delattre à l'origine
d'un texte de loi sur cette question
mais dont on voit qu'il reste encore
beaucoup à faire si on veut préserver
l'évocation attendant les réponses qu'il
faudra nécessairement apporter à ces
défis il faudra accélérer le chantier
national de reconstruction vocable qui
rappelle celui de la prière sinon votre
bâtiment effectivement public ont été
touchés la majorité des dégâts
conservent les biens privés boutiques
commerces entreprises c'est l'objet du
texte d'urgence comme l'examinons
aujourd'hui c'est quand l'exception que
nous appelons que nous apprêtons voter
donner à moins après la vigilance quand
elle s'amuse en service en un
particulier il faudra éviter ainsi les
irrégularités lors des autorisations de
la lucrative et les abus de la courroie
du public qui risquerait de saper la
crédibilité des acteurs publics le texte
ne prévoit pas de nouvelles dépasses
publiques et c'est cohérent avec la
volonté de l'exécutif de renouer avec un
sérieux budgétaire en conclusion les
membres du groupe RDSE votants en faveur
de ce projet de loi de la méditation et
espère un vote conforme de nos collègues
députés ce qui éviteraient de revenir
vendredi
merci merci
monsieur le Président et nous partageons
le vœu final la parole est maintenant
Madame Laure darkose pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
durant plus d'une semaine la France est
trouvée plongée dans le chaos après la
mort de Naël à Nanterre
durant plus d'une semaine de très
nombreuses villes ont été l'otage de la
violence inouïe des émeutiers qui
n'attendait qu'une occasion pour les
lycée libre cours alors haine de notre
pays et de ses institutions il fallait
en découvre avec les forces de l'ordre
et mettre à terre les édifices publics
représentatifs de cette France qu'il ne
respecte pas et dont ils ignorent tous
les codes collectifs
à peine les dernières fumées d'incendie
dissipées certains observateurs se sont
livrés à des critiques absurdes nous
aurions abandonné les quartiers
populaires et mépriser ce qui vivent
péniblement victimes de la pauvreté des
discriminations et du racisme or c'est
tout l'inverse tous les élus le savent
mon département de l'Essonne a été le
théâtre de violon affrontements et a
connu son lot de dégradations et de
pillages mairie école médiathèque maison
de quartier poste de police municipale
commerce RESTAURANT bus et voiture rien
n'a échapper aux destructions mais les
mers ont eu l'intelligence collective de
ne pas trop en faire état sur les
réseaux sociaux et les médias pour
éviter d'exciter ces jeunes qui
faisaient entre eux de la surenchère sur
snapchat d'un quartier à l'autre
rien ne juste de justifier un tel
déchaînement de force contre les
personnes et les biens aujourd'hui le
constat est amère et la colère des élus
de nos communes d'autant plus légitimes
que les émeutiers ont parfois voulu
faire table rase de ces services publics
si indispensables à la population y
compris à eux-mêmes preuves summantes
supplémentaire de leur aveuglement nos
écoles lieu d'apprentissage du vivre
ensemble et de la transmission des
savoirs ont été la cible délibérée des
voyous ces écoles où les enfants
apprennent à user de la raison et à
s'exercer à l'esprit critique sous le
regard bienveillant de leur professeur
hussard de la République abandonné
depuis longtemps par leur ministère et
pourtant le célèbre pédopsychiatre Boris
cyrunique écrivait dans le point de la
semaine dernière ces enfants sont
désespérés car ils ne sont pas tutorisés
pour se spécialiste de l'Atlant petite
enfance ces jeunes désécurisés obéissent
sa des rituels claniques seuls
le plus triste c'est que c'est
délinquants ont surtout puni leur petit
frère et soeurs qui ne pouvant pas
partir en vacances cet été seront privés
des activités culturelles et ludiques
que les maisons de quartier et les
médiathèques l'euro aurait offert
le coût des dommages est insupportable
pour nos communes et pour les
professionnels France assureur estime
qu'il y ait trois fois supérieur à celui
des sinistres occasionnés par les quatre
semaines d'émeutes de l'automne 2005 10
jours après le début des violences
urbaines plus de 11000 sinistres ont été
déclarés pour un coût total de 650
millions d'euros dont 227,5 millions
pour les biens des collectivités
territoriales et 357,5 millions pour
ceux des professionnels dans ce contexte
la première ministre a adressé une
circulaire au préfet du 5 juillet le 5
juillet dernier afin d'accélérer les
procédures de reconstruction et de
réparation je salue cette initiative
dont l'objectif était d'éviter que des
interprétations trop strictes de notre
législation relative aux procédures
d'urbanisme et aux règles de la commande
publique n'entravent la dynamique de
reconstruction
l'exigence de célérité doit prévaloir
sur l'application tatium des normes dont
notre pays s'est faite une spécialité le
projet de loi que le gouvernement soumet
à l'examen du Sénat aujourd'hui comporte
trois articles d'adilation à différé par
ordonnance dans le champ des règles
d'urbanisme de la commande publique et
du financement de la reconstruction
l'article premier a pour objet de
faciliter la reconstruction l'identique
les travaux immédiats et la réduction
des délais l'habilitation prévoit
notamment la possibilité pour les
reconstructions à l'identique
d'appliquer les règles d'urbanisme en
vigueur au moment de la délivrance de
l'autorisation d'urbanisme initiale
ainsi que la faculté de démarrer les
travaux de reconstruction dès le dépôt
de la nouvelle demande l'article 2
autorise à déroger aux règles de
passation et de dévolution des marchés
publics et aux règles de recours au
marché globaux prévus par le code de la
commande publique ainsi il sera permis
au maître d'ouvrage public de conclure
des marchés ou des lots d'un marché sans
publicité mais avec mise en concurrence
préalable pour les travaux inférieurs à
un million d'euros hors taxes et de
s'affranchir de l'obligation
d'aboutissement afin de confier un
opérateur un marché global enfin
l'habilitation de l'article 3 prévoit la
possibilité de subventionner les
collectivités au-delà du plafond de 80%
de déroger au plafonnement des au
plafonnement des fonds de concours
versés entre essayer commune ainsi que
l'accélération des attributions du FCTVA
indéniablement ces dispositions sont de
nature à répondre à la demande des élus
locaux qui veulent rendre à nouveau
accessibles à leur administrer les
services publics de proximité dont ils
ont tant besoin le Sénat est là pour les
entendre et les soutenir notre groupe se
prononcera donc en faveur de ce texte la
reconstruction achevée nous ne pourrons
faire l'économie d'une réflexion sur la
prévention de sa délinquance de plus en
plus précoce sur la nécessité de
restaurer l'autorité de l'État dans les
quartiers gangrénées par le trafic de
drogue sur le besoin d'éducation même
des parents sur la nécessité de la
sanction et de la réparation ainsi que
sur l'accompagnement global des
personnes déclassées je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame Vanina
paoligajin pour les indépendants pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
un policier a ouvert le feu lors d'un
contrôle routier le conducteur mineur
est mort nous le déplorons évidemment
depuis le policier est placé en
détention provisoire
malgré l'enquête en cours malgré la
saisine de la justice afin de faire
toute la lumière sur ses faits notre
pays a connu plusieurs nuits d'émeutes
d'une rare intensité plus de 800 membres
des forces de l'ordre ont été blessés
je veux saluer le professionnalisme des
femmes et des hommes qui sont intervenus
tout au long de cette période comme ils
le font au quotidien pour protéger nos
concitoyens
certains d'entre nous ont été
directement visés par des actions
violentes c'est notamment le cas cela a
été rappelé du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
monsieur Vincent Jean Brun et de sa
famille le groupe Les Indépendants lui
témoignent son entier soutien ainsi qu'à
tous ceux qui ont été victimes de
violence
contestation après contestation nous
voyons ce multiplier de tels actes
contre les élus les violences sont
toujours inacceptables cependant lorsque
les élus sont pris pour cible c'est
aussi la République qui est attaquée
sur fond de crise d'évocation l'avenir
de la démocratie suscite des inquiétudes
bien légitimes il est urgent d'inverser
cette tendance et de retrouver le chemin
du dialogue républicain les récentes
émeutes confirment que brûler n'est ni
un programme ni une solution
comme beaucoup d'autres départements
l'aube n'a pas été épargnée ces
événements ont engendré un bilan
matériel très lourd encore en cours de
chiffrage je pense notamment auprès de 2
millions d'euros qui avait coûté la
maison de quartier des Sénarts à Troyes
on ne compte plus les commerces détruits
les salles de classe dégradées les
mairies incendiées cela a été répété
glorifiant le vandalisme le plus stérile
nous avons vu fleurir sur les réseaux
sociaux en forme d'appel de la tribu les
défis les plus délétères
certains l'ignorent sans doute mais le
pouvoir de brûler une voiture n'est qui
vaut pas à celui de la construire la
vraie puissance appartient au bâtisseurs
elle n'appartient pas au casseurs depuis
les émeutes ceux qui n'avaient pas grand
chose ont encore moins
les assureurs évaluent les dégâts cela a
été rappelé à plus de 650 millions
d'euros ces événements auraient en outre
coûté à notre économie plus de 300
millions d'euros donc quelques 500
communes concernées plus de 800
bâtiments publics ont été dégradés se
posent maintenant la question de leur
réparation
le principe d'une loi d'urgence pour
reconstruire au frais du contribuable
des bâtiments détruits par des émeutiers
peut laisser perplexe
l'État doit-il se presser de financer
les dégâts causés par ceux qui sont son
prix à notre République
le groupe Les Indépendants considèrent
qu'il est urgent de reconstruire non
pour les émeutiers mais pour tous les
autres
vous le savez bien mes chers collègues
hormis quelques fanatiques encouragés
par l'irresponsable et inflammable
France insoumise hormis quelques
opportunistes l'immense majorité de nos
concitoyens souhaitent que le calme
revienne pour que la justice puisse
faire sereinement son travail pour que
nos concitoyens puissent reprendre le
cours de leurs activités tout savent
bien que ce n'est que par le travail que
l'individu peut s'émanciper nous voulons
dire à ceux de nos concitoyens qui
vivent dans des quartiers difficiles et
qui n'ont pas fait le choix de la
délinquance à ceux qui sont allés
travailler plutôt que piller que la
République ne les abandonne pas
ce travail de reconstruction sera
également l'occasion de démontrer la
puissance publique la République doit
être présente à cet égard sur l'ensemble
du territoire de notre pays
au-delà de la réparation des dégâts nous
sommes convaincus que ce travail de
restauration devra être poursuivi
restaurer l'état monsieur le ministre
dans ses capacités et dans son autorité
nous devons collectivement veiller à ce
que les lois de la République soient
appliquées sur l'ensemble du territoire
notre groupe Les Indépendants soutiendra
donc l'adoption de ce texte première
étape d'un retour de l'État que nous
appelons ardemment de nos vœux je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant au président Claude
Reynal pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du Sénat monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
en complément de mon collègue et ami
Christian Redon sarrazzi qui tout à
l'heure a dit l'essentiel donc il me
reste le reste
quelques mots sur l'article 3 du projet
de loi
les violences urbaines qui se sont
déroulées entre le 27 juin et le 5
juillet vont probablement coûter
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
qu'il va falloir maintenant prendre en
charge
le maintien de l'ordre public relève
exclusivement de la compétence de l'État
à la suite des émeutes de 2005 certaines
collectivités avaient d'ailleurs demandé
au juge de reconnaître la responsabilité
sans faute de l'État
au-delà des interrogations légitimes et
des réponses politiques qu'appellent ces
événements
l'état logiquement doit être rendez-vous
pour financer la reconstruction des
biens dégradés ou démoli
avec l'article 3 du présent projet de
loi celui-ci souhaite donc faciliter les
reconstructions des biens c'est
indéniablement une bonne chose
l'article prévoit trois points nous
l'avons dit rembourser dans l'année le
FCTVA supprimer à la fois la
participation minimale d'une
collectivité à un projet qu'elle porte
ainsi que la limite concernant le
montant total des fonds de concours
ces propositions vont dans le bon sens
sur le fond il y a évidemment quelques
imprécisions qui auraient pu être levées
sur la modification des dépenses ouvre
en droit au FCTVA le gouvernement ne
précise pas à ce stade ces intentions
par exemple l'allocation mais il y a
beaucoup d'autres exemples la location
des structures temporaires peut-elle
être dans le champ de remboursement
sur le sujet de la participation
financière minimale si le bornage dans
le temps est de fait prévu par le
dispositif qui restreint au seul dommage
occasionné par les émeutes cette
dérogation on peut néanmoins
s'interroger sur la formule dommage
directement causé qui pourrait ouvrir un
certain champ de contestation
sur la question des fonds de concours je
note aussi une absence de précision
quant à la typologie des travaux prise
en charge que l'ordonnance évidemment
devra préciser
il ne s'agit pas en l'espèce seulement
de faciliter le reconstruction il faut
aussi bien sûr les financer et les
solutions budgétaires peuvent être
multiples mais à ce stade nous n'en
savons pas grand chose création d'un
vent exceptionnel il y a bien sûr un
petit fond qui a été mis en place mais
on sait bien qu'il est insuffisant
avance subventions etc en associant les
parlementaires et les élus locaux il
doit y avoir de la part du gouvernement
des propositions budgétaires concrètes
qui n'appachent donc pas à ce stade
au regard du contexte économique ou les
collectivités territoriales sont tenues
de maîtriser leurs dépenses dès la
rentrée le groupe socialiste portera des
propositions pour soutenir nos élus
locaux et au plus tard lors de l'examen
du PLF de fin de gestion
d'une manière générale les ordonnances à
menuisent nous le savons le rôle des
parlementaires le Parlement ne peut pas
être ne pas être qu'une seule chambre
d'approbation ou d'enregistrement en
conséquence il me paraît opportun de
créer un comité de suivi afin de donner
à voir en toute transparence ce qui est
fait nous devons être en capacité de
suivre l'évolution des reconstructions
des bâtiments dégradés ou démolis malgré
ces quelques réserves le groupe
socialiste écologique et républicain
votera nous l'avons dit pour ce texte je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
monsieur le président
la parole est maintenant madame Daphné
ratemadou pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du Sénat monsieur le ministre
chers collègues
Arpajon Athis-Mons Bondoufle
Chilly-Mazarin
corbeille Essonne Dourdan Draveil
Épinay-sous-Sénart étampes Évry
Courcouronnes Fleury-Mérogis
Gif-sur-Yvette Grigny Juvisy-sur-Orge
Les Ulis Massy Saint-Germain-lès-Corbeil
Saint-Michel-sur-Orge Saint-Jean
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois
Savigny-sur-Orge Vigneux ou
Viry-Châtillon
ceci n'est malheureusement pas un cours
de géographie et sonnienne mais la liste
non exhaustive des communes de mon
département qui ont été touchées par les
émeutes
derrière le drame du décès de Naël
Merzouk est la nécessaire enquête qui
doit s'en suivre rien d'excuse les
violences les dégradations et les
pillages qui ont eu lieu dans toute la
France rien d'excuse les dégâts humains
moraux matériels et financiers rien
d'excuse enfin les attaques répétées
contre des institutions qui sont le
ciment de notre République
j'ai en effet une pensée toute
particulière pour les élus locaux et des
agents publics sur le pont jour et nuit
qui ont vu leur mairie et endommagée
comme celle de Dourdan pour les enfants
qui ont vu leurs écoles être saccagées
comme celle de Viry-Châtillon pour les
habitants de ricourcouronnes et leur
maison de quartier et pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens qui ont vu leurs
équipements leur service de transport et
leur commerce du quotidien est dégradé
et détruit
nous avons vu des pompiers encerclés
avoir peur des policiers municipés
municipaux assiégés certains élus être
agressés et d'autres éteindre les
incendies extincteurs toujours à portée
de main dans le coffre
à l'aune de ces réalités il nous faut
nous poser les bonnes questions et tirer
de ces événements tragiques des
enseignements pour nos territoires et
notre jeunesse il est de notre
responsabilité de prendre le temps du
débat démocratique d'échanger avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de nos quartiers
afin d'éviter tout avant aveuglement
malheureux la gravité de ces événements
ne doit être ni ignoré ni minimiser le
coût inédite se dégradation parfaitement
mise en lumière par ma collègue
Françoise Ferrat rendait nécessaire le
dépôt rapide d'un projet de loi je salue
à ce titre le recours aux ordonnances
qui plutôt qu'une rédaction prise dans
l'urgence laissera le temps à l'état de
mettre en oeuvre un plan adéquate et
permettra de consulter largement les
représentants des principales victimes
l'accompagnement de chacun doit être
notre priorité ce projet de loi répond à
cette impératif j'appelle de mes vœux
une mobilisation forte de notre
institution sur cette question mes chers
collègues les causes et les conséquences
de ce déchaînement de violence dans nos
territoires devront être étudiés et
questionnés tout comme le plan de
reconstruction une mission sénatoriale
d'enquête ou l'information me semble
rien ainsi tout à fait approprié plus
qu'une reconstruction matérielle et
financière certes éminemment nécessaire
et urgente j'espère que notre démocratie
transformera la conflictualité brûlante
de ses émeutes en un puissant ferment
permettant de rebâtir des fondations
solides et républicaines dans nos
communes des fondations où le dialogue
apaisé trouvera toute sa place et où les
symboles de notre République
continueront d'être des lieux de
rassemblement plutôt que de destruction
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Bruno Belin pour les
groupes les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
le Président carochi dont je salue cette
séance particulière dans votre
engagement au Sénat monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente prima monsieur le
vice-président même la rapporteur
mes chers collègues cette semaine
malheureuse de cast et des meutres que
nous avons vécu à le mérite d'apporter
quelques vertus
ça fait corps avec ce qui fait la
République et réaffirmer le total
soutien aux élus locaux aux pompiers à
l'ensemble des services de l'État police
gendarmerie corps préfectoral totalement
mobilisé chacun y en fait preuve
d'engagement et d'efficacité cela nous
permet ce matin de parler
simplifications monsieur le ministre par
obligation c'était l'objet initial de la
loi 3DS
sans doute insuffisante peut-être
incomplète
voire décevante selon certains
c'est casseurs stupides hors la loi qui
ont brûlé leur mairie leur école leur
pharmacie voir leur bureau de poste
pourtant si important pour le versement
de leur minima sociaux nous permettent
ce matin de desserrer
les trous nombreux freins qui
contraignent
trop souvent les motivations les
ambitions les respirations des
territoires et vont donner aux élus
locaux de nouvelles possibilités de
nouvelles prérogatives et je l'espère de
nouvelles perspectives pour aller vite
faire confiance à la France pratique
mais aujourd'hui Monsieur le Ministre
pourquoi n'irions nous pas plus loin
d'accord il y a le court terme c'est
l'objet de ce matin faut réparer
reconstruire et puis il faudra très vite
avoir de nouveaux textes
pour éviter que cela ne se reproduise
peut-être généralisé la vidéo
surveillance décidez de peine plancher
et les appliquer être clair
cassé c'est payé et puis ensuite
pourquoi ne pas faire de
l'extraordinaire de ce matin
l'ordinaire de demain
supprimer les contraintes les normes les
diagnostics les études les comités de
suivi les comités de pilotage les
dossiers tout ce qui fait perdre du
temps au projet tout ce qui coûte tout
ce qui use les élus vous savez très bien
qu'il y a des choses
vous savez très bien qu'il y a des
éléments qui sont facilement puisqu'on
les individus ce matin
retirables on peut effectivement ne plus
avoir ce plafond de vin pour cent
d'autofinancement pour un projet à
partir du moment où il est financé on
peut envisager de récupérer la TVA la
même année on le fait bien pour les
entreprises et les commerces on peut ne
pas avoir forcément le service fait pour
pouvoir toucher des avances et donc
bénéficier au
trésorerie des collectivités
les élus ont besoin de ceci ont besoin
de ces messages au moment où nous allons
chercher des élus au risque d'en manquer
pour s'occuper de nos si précieuses
communes
donnons leur l'espérance et les moyens
de faire ce pourquoi il s'engage
façonner leur ville de demain
et rendent plus aisé le quotidien
liberté égalité fraternité moins de
papier
faire en sorte que la France de la
paperasse fasse plus de place à la
France de l'audace faisons
urgemment le pari de la France de
l'agilité de la flexibilité de la
fluidité
c'est la France de la proximité celle
que nous côtoyons tous les jours c'est
la France de la rapidité c'est ce que
nous voulons aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
madame Alexandra borque au fond de teint
pour le beau-père républicain pour 4
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
mesdames et messieurs et monsieur le
rapporteur les rapporteurs monsieur le
Président du Sénat mes chers collègues
école bibliothèque commissariat mairie
centre socio-commerce ou pharmacie voici
la liste non exhaustive des bâtiments
qui lors des récentes et mesures
urbaines ont été attaquées dégradés
incendié démolis élèves citoyen mer
policier gendarmes pompiers patrons et
employés voilà cette fois la liste des
victimes de ces délinquants plus de 2500
bâtiments pillés par une poignée de
criminels et des millions de Français à
devoir en payer l'addition face à ces
images de déferlement d'une violence
inouïe la nation entière doit s'unir
autour de ses forces de sécurité de ces
élus locaux et j'en passe l'urgence
aujourd'hui c'est de reconstruire les
bâtiments détruits dans les meilleurs
délais c'était d'ailleurs l'objet de la
proposition de loi déposée par ma
collègue Sophie prima soutenu sans
réserve par le président du Sénat visant
à lever les obstacles en matière de
réglementation de l'urbanisme je me
réjouis que nous ayons été entendus avec
l'examen de ce projet de loi similaire
et je saluer bien sûr le travail des
rapporteurs pour cette raison notre
groupe les républicains votera bien sûr
ce texte pourquoi parce qu'il s'agit
d'une urgence économique mais surtout
d'une urgence républicaine alors
évidemment je partage la vie de nos
compatriotes ce sont toujours les mêmes
qui payent mais on ne peut pas laisser
des enfants sans école ou des citoyens
sans service public n'ajoutons pas du
chaos au chaos il y a quatre jours nous
célébrions la France son drapeau son
histoire mais en l'état de notre société
était un jour de gloire ou de défaite 17
atteintes aux élus ont été recensés les
enfants d'un maire ont été attaqués à
leur domicile il est temps de protéger
ceux qui sont en première ligne et
d'aggraver les peines pour les auteurs
de violence alors en contre Monsieur le
Ministre il nous faut retrouver de
l'ordre c'est la vocation première de
l'État pour surmonter cette crise
civique majeure la peur de ne pas nous
affaiblir et l'image des feux d'artifice
du 14 juillet doit symboliser notre
volonté de ne jamais rien à quiconque
nous devesserons ni les bras ni les yeux
soyons lucides la mort récente de ce
jeune homme a servi de prétexte à ses
délinquants pour saccager tout ce qui se
trouvait sur leur passage mineur pour
beaucoup ils ont crié leur haine de la
France les refus d'obtempérer toutes les
20 minutes en France combien de temps
allons-nous accepter cette défiance
manifeste en faire nos forces de l'ordre
donc envers l'État parmi les pays
d'Europe seule la France connaît de tels
émeutes et ce alors que les difficultés
sociales n'épargnaient pas nos voisins
il faut le dire et le redire notre
société bascule dans l'ensommagement
alors face aux délitement acté de notre
République des grands devoirs s'imposent
à nous rétablir une réponse pénale
dissuasive avec notamment un
accroissement de la capacité carcérale a
baisser la majorité pénale à 16 ans
rendre les parents des mineurs des lacs
pénalement responsables transformés
notre école avec une défense affirmée de
la nation et de la laïcité soutenir sans
relâche nos forces de sécurité remettre
l'autorité au centre de notre société
des propositions pour restaurer l'ordre
public que nous défendons au sein des
républicains qui ont notamment été
présentés par nos présidents de groupe
Bruno Retailleau aujourd'hui l'incendie
semble maîtriser grâce au travail
acharné de nos forces de secours et de
sécurité mais jusqu'à quand des zones
incandescentes menacent à tout moment de
s'embraser de nouveau n'attendons pas et
soyons au rendez-vous pour ne plus subir
ces violences inacceptables et ont
payées encore l'addition
merci
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close nous passons au texte
de la Commission à l'article premier la
parole est à Monsieur Michel Cannet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues effectivement
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure dans votre exposé
liminaire l'objet de ce texte n'est pas
d'examiner les causes des incidents qui
nous rassemblent aujourd'hui mais
néanmoins il faut se poser la question
de savoir comment autant de jeunes
puisque selon les statistiques du
ministère d'intérieur ce c’était des
mineurs qui pour l'essentiel se
trouvaient dans les rues à des heures
particulièrement tardives comme comment
entendre mineur peuvent se trouver dans
les rues aussi tardivement et à réaliser
des dégâts tels qu'on a pu les observer
en tout cas des dégradations tout à fait
conséquentes et tout ceci amène à se
poser des questions sur la question de
l'autorité parentale et à se dire qu'il
faudra que l'on réfléchisse sur les
mesures à mettre en œuvre pour
éviter que de
scénario ne se reproduise à l'avenir en
tout cas nous aurons un travail
collectif à effectuer et je souhaitais
monsieur le ministre effectuer la prise
de parole sur cet article pour me
réjouir bien sûr qu'il y ait des
dispositions permettant
d'accélérer la remise en état des
immeubles qui ont été dégradés
c'est mesures portent essentiellement
sur les dispositions du Code de
l'Urbanisme pour alléger l'instruction
il me semble aussi nécessaire peut-être
que dans l'habilitation par ordonnance
vous puissiez regarder la question des
recours parce qu'il ne faudrait pas
qu'il y ait des recours qui amènent à
devoir
retarder significativement les
opérations de reconstruction que nous
souhaitons tous ardemment voir mise en
œuvre donc il convient peut-être de
regarder cet aspect là aussi monsieur le
ministre
merci Madame Brulin
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du Sénat monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues cet article était-il
indispensable il semblerait que non si
on en croit la circulaire du 5 juillet
dernier où vous disiez l'inverse on vous
appuyant sur l'article
l11-15 du Code de l'Urbanisme mais
rassurez-vous nous le voterons sans
ergoter comme nous voterons les articles
suivants mais je voudrais saisir
l'occasion de ce premier article pour
dire que bien évidemment il faut
reconstruire et le plus rapidement
possible les services publics mais qu'il
faut pas seulement reconstruire les
bâtiments mais l'ensemble des services
que nous devons rendre à la population
et engager une sorte de reconquête
républicaine un réinvestissement des
services publics dans les quartiers
populaires dans les villes moyennes dans
la ruralité face à des habitants qui
dans la diversité de ces territoires ce
sont de plus en plus abandonnés je crois
que il est la République est souvent
invoquée dans des discours il faut
qu'elle s'incarne dans une présence de
proximité une présence humaine une
présence efficace
utile à nos concitoyens vous allez dire
je m'écarte du texte qui nous rassemble
aujourd'hui mais pas du contexte
plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont évoqué et
pour
illustrer ce propos sur quelques-uns des
services publics essentiels je voudrais
dire que la rentrée scolaire ne doit pas
à nos yeux s'effectuer comme c'est rien
de s'était passé on sait qu'il y a des
classes qui restent surchargées on sait
qu'il y a des enseignants qui ne seront
de nouveau pas remplacés au cours de
l'année laissant des élèves avec des
heures considérables
d'enseignement qui vont leur manquer
avec des académies qui connaissent des
crises de recrutement considérables et
des enseignants qui ne seront pas là
devant les classes à la rentrée et que
il nous semble que ce chantier est au
moins aussi urgent que celui qui nous
rassemble ce matin merci
c'est Monsieur ça vole délit
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Miss mes chers collègues si nous sommes
deux de notre groupe à intervenir c'est
parce que la présidente Eliana Sassi
avait demandé à Madame borne que nous
ayons à débat au Parlement sur les
causes des événements que nous venons de
subir donc bien évidemment faut voter en
urgence la réflexion la rabbitation des
bâtiments et l'extension qui est proposé
avec les bailleurs sociaux mais je vous
le dis sur le ministre vous dites à
juste titre que des symboles de la
République ont été dégradés
mais il faut qu'on en tire les leçons il
nous faut une date de débat il nous faut
une organisation pour débattre de ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi ça s'est passé
et nous nous pensons qu'il y a un gros
problème c'est qu'il faut tirer tous les
enseignements pour reconnaître et
respecter toute la population française
respecter et reconnaître toute la
population française il n'y a trop
d'inégalités devant la République
Monsieur le Ministre et ça il faut en
débattre
et dont vous devez à mon avis dans votre
rôle nous donner un rendez-vous de débat
politique
parce que évidemment ces émeutes
naissent quand même d'un vide politique
ns une absence de relais de sociaux
Ernest demande de conflit au bon sens du
terme les conflits des idées les
conflits qui animent la démocratie la
démocratie directe comme la démocratie
représentative donc notre groupe avait
demandé qu'on est à la fois ces mesures
d'urgence pour être aux côtés des
collectivités bien évidemment des
bailleurs mais aussi qu'on a un débat de
fond excusez-moi parce que notre société
traversée par beaucoup de problèmes donc
vraiment il faudrait qu'on ait un
rendez-vous pour que on corrige les
inégalités devant la République et
reconnaissent et respecte toute la
population et j'ai bien dit toute la
population merci
amendement deux monsieur Redon sarrazi
et bien je ne l'avais point vu et vous
n'aviez pas dû lever le doigt très haut
et bien allons-y
je serai très brève Président je
poursuis les propos de Monsieur
Savoldelli
pour les mêmes raisons le président du
président de mon groupe Patrick kaner
avait écrit à la première ministre pour
lui demander qu'un débat 50- puisse se
tenir sur ce sujet les jours ont passé
sans réponse et la réponse est à
réveiller pour décliner la proposition
et la demande en indiquant qu'il fallait
réfléchir réfléchir et d'une très bonne
chose donc nous allons demander à ce que
après le délai de réflexion c'est-à-dire
à la rentrée parlementaire à nouveau
nous puissions enfin avoir ce débat car
vous l'avez noté tout le monde débat
partout de ce qui s'est passé en France
sauf au Parlement ce n'est pas normal
merci
amendement de Monsieur Redon Sarrazy oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre si vous autorisez monsieur le
Président donc je défendrai les
amendements 2 3 et 4 qui sont de même
nature donc le 4 juillet le président de
la République a réuni les maires des
villes particulièrement touchées par les
violences urbaines il l'aura annoncé un
projet de loi d'urgence pour accélérer
les chantiers de reconstruction et de
réflexion le gouvernement a traduit la
volonté du chef de l'État par un texte
d'habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnance donc acte toutefois les
délais de deux voire trois mois prévu
pour la publication de ces ordonnances
nous conduisent potentiellement à
disposer de mesures concrètes à la fin
du mois d'octobre ces délais
contredisent le discours affiché de
l'urgence notre amendement propose donc
de prévoir la publication des
ordonnances au plus tard le 31 juillet
et c'est tout à fait réaliste depuis le
4 juillet cela laissait quasiment un
mois pour préparer des mesures des
mesures qui relèvent de ministère
différents et qui sont sans difficulté
particulière il s'agit avec cet
amendement garantir l'effectivité du
critère d'urgence qui est invoqué cette
urgence qui justifie d'ailleurs que le
Parlement accepte de légiférer dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles qu'on se
le dise aussi les mesures attendues avec
ce texte sont une portée très limitée au
regard de l'ampleur des reconstructions
à engager mais ce texte est important
car il envoie un signal de mobilisation
et de solidarité aux populations qui
sont les premières victimes de ces
dégradations la dynamique de
reconstruction des centres villes et des
quartiers doit se mettre en place
rapidement sinon les habitants risquent
de se sentir de nouveau abandonnés vous
l'aurez compris mes chers collègues
notre objectif avec cet amendement c'est
bien d'accompagner les collectivités à
organiser rapidement les opérations de
reconstruction car oui il y a bien
urgence à redonner aux habitants leur
cadre de vie leur commerce leur service
de proximité il y a urgence à restaurer
la continuité des services publics dans
toutes les communes qui ont subi des
dégradations l'urgence de la
reconstruction c'est bien il me semble
ce qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
merci avis la commission sur ces trois
amendements qui sont les mêmes
le me contenterait de donner la vie
sur cet amendement numéro 2 puisque les
deux autres sont dans les deux
commissions différentes je les dis tout
à l'heure de mon exposé
un délai d'habilitation de trois mois
n'empêche pas le gouvernement de prendre
les mesures déjà identifiées dans les
tous prochains jours je suis sûre que
monsieur le ministre le précisera tout à
l'heure je vous rejoins sur le fait
qu'il y a urgence à ne pas attendre mais
ce délai de trois mois permet aussi de
laisser un peu de marge de manœuvre pour
compléter au besoin cette première salle
de mesure si au cours de l'été ou à la
rentrée de nouveaux cas émergent qui
nécessiteraient d'autres adaptations de
nature législatives j'ajoute que c'est
le Conseil d'État lui-même qui dans son
avis à suggéré que nous allons jouer ce
débat ce délai à trois mois donc avis
retrait ou avis défavorable
ment
la présidente prima vient d'évoquer le
fait que c'est le Conseil d'État
lui-même qui sur la base des deux mois
que nous imaginions a suggérer qu'on
passe à trois mois je vais vous dire que
malgré la volonté d'aller vite on a
quelques délais incompressibles nous
devons saisir le Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes nous devons
saisir le Conseil d'État et nous devons
inscrire au Conseil des ministres le
texte en partant de l'hypothèse que nous
ayons à votre confort
nous gagnons quelques jours et donc je
ne saurais que trop souhaité que ce soit
évidemment l'issue de cette semaine mais
plus largement penser qu'en 10 jours
puisque ça ferait ça pour le 31 juillet
avec une date d'adoption le vin on
serait en capacité de pouvoir revenir
vers vous ça ne serait pas rassurant sur
ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur j'en veux
pour preuve le fait que vos travaux en
commission nous ont conduit à déposer
l'amendement 5 que j'aurai l'occasion de
défendre pour vérifier que sur la voirie
que sur les équipements publics on
n'oublie pas une partie des choses et de
la même manière le temps de
consolidation d'une partie des dégâts
peut nous amener peut être précieux de
ce point de vue pour faire en sorte
d'élargir donc j'ai mis un avis demande
de retrait à vie défavorable sur les
trois sujets et puis je répondrai juste
d'un mot puisque la question a été posée
de beaucoup de choses peuvent se faire
par décret oui mais j'utiliserai les
propos de Daniel salmon refaire à
l'identique mais en tenant compte des
nouvelles normes de sécurité ou
environnementales ça n'est pas
exactement refaire à l'identique et donc
ça suppose d'avoir une habilitation qui
passe par la loi ce qui devra peut-être
au-delà du débat qui nous occupe
d'ailleurs nous inciter à réfléchir sur
nos procédures de manière plus large
merci monsieur le ministre je mets aux
voix l'amendement 2 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
il est rejeté je mets je vois l'article
premier qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté
à l'article 2 donc l'amendement 3
défendu préalablement
est-ce que il y a un avis différent
évidemment de la commission oui madame
dufolko merci monsieur le Président la
vie sera le même mais pas tout à fait
avec les mêmes motifs je partageais
effectivement chers collègue votre
souhait que l'ordonnance soit publiée le
plus tôt possible j'ai invité le
ministre le faire si possible au dernier
conseil des ministres avant la pause
estivale j'aurais été à ma demande on ne
sait jamais peut-être que notre
ordonnance est plus simple à écrire que
que les autres voilà donc mais avis
défavorable merci
gouvernement ma vie par définition
l'interpellation de la présidente à
répondre n'ayant pas je ne me lèverai
pas au dessus de ma condition je n'ai
aucune maîtrise sur l'ordre du jour du
conseil des ministres nous travaillons
pour aller aussi vite que possible sur
chacun des articles des bouchons sur
chacune des ordonnances c'est une date
butoir plus vite nous pourrons aller
plus vite nous irons
merci
je remets aux voix même si j'imagine que
c'est le même vote l'amendement numéro 3
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté l'amendement 5
monsieur le ministre amendement du
Gouvernement
donc dans les interpellations qui m'ont
été faites ce matin la tribune et qui
l'ont été plus largement au cours de vos
débats en commission il y en a de
plusieurs ordres certaines en
particulier qui te tendaient à préciser
que ça ne pouvait qu'une catégorie des
dégradations pouvait avoir affecté autre
chose que des bâtiments et en citant du
mobilier urbain en citant
en particulier des éléments de de voirie
d'éclairage public de réseau de
transport
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui vous
est présenté répond très précisément à
cette demande en élargissant au delà des
bâtiments aux équipements publics la
liste de ce qui pourrait être concerné
par les dispositions j'ajoute que nous
avons fait un petit rédactionnel pour
que le mot public ne porte que sur les
équipements et que le mot bâtiment ce
soit le mot affecté qu'il définisse de
manière à ce que des bâtiments privés
puissent bénéficier évidemment des
dispositions de l'ordonnance que vous
nous habiliterez à prendre si vous votez
de manière favorable et je remercie le
Sénat pour les remarques pas seulement
rédactionnelles mais même de fonds qui
éviteront que nous ayons ce trou dans la
raquette au moment de nous retourner
vers les élus
merci Monsieur le Ministre avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président ce serait
évidemment un avis favorable puisqu'il
y a simplement monsieur le ministre
puisque nous avons pratiquement au terme
du texte de vous reposer la question
concernant le seuil parce que vous ne
m'avez pas répondu alors c'est pour donc
vous prépariez votre réponse je vous
remercie en tout cas un avis favorable
le ministre a l'air tout prêt à vous
répondre tout de suite
nous allons également vous écouter sur
le fait de ne pas nous limiter à un
million d'euros on ira certainement pas
jusqu'au 5,3 qui sont prévus par les
seuils européens pour plein de raisons
mais parmi ces raisons il y a aussi le
fait qu'il y a la disposition de la
taille du marché qui entraînerait un
défaut de concurrence transfrontalière
sur un certain nombre de projets donc
j'entre pas dans le détail la marge on
peut aller au-delà du million mais un
seuil et 1,5 millions d'euros qui permet
déjà d'aller gagner nous semble être un
point d'arrivée je vois faire des gestes
de la main qui fait que les gens qui
sont derrière moi ne voient pas que vous
souhaitez que manifestement on augmente
le niveau
je vous fais ce premier élément de
réponse aujourd'hui les services
travaillent mais nous nous limiterons
pas au million d'euros
merci
je vais donc mettre voix l'amendement 5
du gouvernement avec un avis favorable
de la commission qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté je mets aux voiles 2 qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté à l'article
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le gouvernement
a forte opportunité opportunément
proposé dans cet article de ramener à
l'année même de l'investissement la
possibilité pour les collectivités
concernées de pouvoir bénéficier du
FCTVA alors je pense que c'est une
excellente disposition mais si le
gouvernement l'a retenu pour ce texte je
pense que cette disposition aurait
intérêt à pouvoir s'appliquer de manière
générale aussi à l'ensemble des
collectivités de notre pays puisqu'il se
trouve qu'il reste encore un grand
nombre de collectivités qui aujourd'hui
ne perçoivent le bénéfice du fcta que
l'année N+1 voire même la nièce n + 2 ce
qui est en déconnexion totale avec le
moment où l'on a réalisé
l'investissement et donc cela ne se
justifie absolument plus et donc je je
me suis le ministre que dans le cadre de
la prochaine loi de finances il serait
opportun que nous puissions avoir un
système de bénéfice du FCTVA qui soit
identique pour tout le monde à tout le
moins à tout le moins qu'on supprime
le la question du N+2 qui n'a pas de
sens et donc j'invite le gouvernement à
réfléchir à cela et à formuler des
propositions donc très rapidement de
façon à ce que cela puisse également
permettre d'accompagner les
collectivités dans leurs investissements
et puis dernier point que je souhaite
évoquer c'est la question des
ordonnances puisque
l'habilitation pour trois ordonnances
sont formulées dans le texte qui nous
est soumis j'avais de le gouvernement à
faire en sorte que ces ordonnances
puissent être effectivement ensuite
ratifiée par le Parlement car il est
anormal que dans notre pays il y est
encore des dispositions qui fassent que
les ordonnances ne soient pas toujours
ratifiées par le Parlement or il me
paraît de bonne logique
dès lors qu'on habite le gouvernement
par ordonnance qu'il revienne vers le
Parlement pour les ratifier merci
Monsieur le testeur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président du Sénat monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
j'approuve tout ce qu'on dit mes
collègues sur cet article 3 mais je
voulais profiter du fait que ce sera
sans doute ma dernière intervention au
Sénat mes chers collègues pour vous dire
mon grand attachement au Big amerisme et
au Sénat pour vous dire aussi que la
généralisation absolue de la procédure
d'urgence et quelque chose de délétère
qui porte atteinte à la qualité de la
loi pour dire aussi que l'usage excessif
de l'article 45 de la Constitution pose
problème et que comme vient de le dire
notre collègue la ratification des
ordonnances devrait être Express je
profite si vous le permettez monsieur le
Président de la minute qui me reste de
votre bienveillance pour remercier très
chaleureusement les administrateurs
administra
teur adjoints du Sénat les personnels
des trois comptes rendus
et tous les personnels du Sénat dont
j'ai pu bénéficier durant 22 ans de la
très grande qualité du très grand
dévouement je leur dis de tout cœur
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci pour Monsieur le testeur la parole
est à Monsieur Pascal Savoldelli
et merci monsieur le ministre il y a eu
plein d'hommages moi j'avoue que j'étais
ému l'autre jour quand le président
Larcher a salué le travail de notre
président de groupe et vous avez vu
qu'elle était émue aussi et c'est une
belle reconnaissance du pluralisme et
une belle reconnaissance d'humanité
entre un grand nombre d'entre nous
peut-être pas l'unanimité mais un grand
nombre d'entre nous donc merci aussi
pour ça pour la reconnaissance du
politique
on est sur un article qui concerne les
finances moi je voulais vous dire que
notre groupe se félicite que la
commission des lois est élargie au
bailleur sociaux
parce que quand même ils viennent de se
faire fonctionner 1,3 milliards avant
les émeutes par la réduction du loyer de
solidarité donc heureusement qu'il y a
eu cette démarche là donc ça nous fait
un après et puis après monsieur le
ministre avoir des certitudes parce que
les élus demandent des certitudes des
garanties dans les relations entre
l'État les collectivités donc si j'ai
bien compris vous allez utiliser les
crédits provisionnels ouverts en loi de
finance initiale pour 2023 soit 40
millions sur le ministre
et après vous dites que vous allez
utiliser les moyens de la réserve de
précaution du programme 122 ce qui fait
12 millions je vous avoue je suis
préoccupé nous sommes préoccupés parce
que ce volume qui pourrait correspondre
à 40 millions plus les 12 millions de
loi programme du programme 122 je pense
que c'est bien en deux ça des besoins
que l'État doit apporter aux
collectivités territoriales au bailleur
et aux populations donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner des éléments bien
plus larges du point de vue du la
réalité la sincérité du périmètre de
l'aide de l'État merci
monsieur le ministre
je prends cette possibilité de
d'intervenir comme un clin d'œil
personnel j'ai été accueilli dans cette
maison
la commission des lois par le président
sueur et d'être là le jour où il
prononce ces derniers mots
sa boucle là aussi une boucle
voilà
comme quoi vous voyez que il est de
bonne politique que c'est des bananes
dure pas trop longtemps
à tout point de vue pour répondre sur le
fond
le FCTVA ça n'est pas un dispositif
récent nouveau il y a un certain
d'ajustements qui ont été conduits le
coût pour les finances publiques il
n'existe qu'en une fois mais c'est
l'année où vous décidez de tout
rembourser à la fois les années
précédentes et la même année et le
chiffrage il est aux alentours de 6
milliards d'euros
5,3 pour être précis sur la base des
deux dernières années mais en fonction
de l'année où vous le déclenchez de la
temporalité notamment des projets
municipaux vous avez un impact qui n'est
pas le même je laisse à chacun réfléchir
sur ce que ça représente et sur l'impact
que ça peut avoir
sur le dispositif financier qui est
derrière le projet de loi qui vous est
soumis
c'est 94 millions d'euros qui sont
immédiatement disponibles aujourd'hui
mais à vrai dire c'est pas ça le vrai
sujet le vrai sujet c'est que nous avons
donné jusqu'au 30 septembre pour que les
collectivités locales nous fasse
remonter leurs besoins parce qu'on
considère que le risque là aussi c'est
dans l'oublier donc on se tourne vers
les élus pour qui nous indique quels
sont les dégâts qu'ils ont subi en
parallèle les préfets en l'obligation de
faire l'évaluation des dégâts et enfin
il faut déduire les primes d'assurance
la somme que nous aurons à mettre c'est
pas seulement le coût consolidé des
travaux c'est bien le delta entre ce qui
est couvert par les assurances et ce qui
pourrait l'être à un autre titre donc le
détail on ne le connaîtra de toute façon
pas avant le mois d'octobre et ça tombe
bien parce que c'est le moment où nous
aurons à ce moment là le début de la
discussion budgétaire donc je redis les
sommes qui sont en place ne sont en
aucune manière une limite dans ce qui
serait la capacité à agir
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
saumon
[Applaudissements]
là
factuellement
nous ne pouvons pas utiliser une
ordonnance pour défaire ce que la loi de
finances a fait sinon ce serait allé
très loin dans ce que le réglementaire
permet
en revanche
cette question dont je sais l'émotion
qu'elle suscite ce que noix de finances
a fait une autre loi puisque une loi a
défait une autre loi de finance peut le
faire je pense que nous pourrions faire
over utile par rapport à ce qui nous
remonte des territoires sur ces
exclusions de FCTVA pour une partie de
ces aménagements dans quelques semaines
pour un coup qui est de l'ordre de 200
millions d'euros quand même mais qui me
semble correspondre aussi aux besoins y
compris pour accompagner une nation
sportive qui se prépare à accueillir des
grands événements
merci
et l'amendement 4 a été défendu et j'ai
besoin de la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
merci de me donner la parole je remercie
de Monsieur le Ministre de ces
ouvertures sur le FCTVA et je pense que
nous saurons nous en souvenir
effectivement au moment de la discussion
de la loi de finance et pour répondre au
président de la commission des finances
et c'est amendement moi je crois qu'il
faut pas confondre vitesse et
précipitations c'est vrai qu'on a tous
envie que ça aille très vite en même
temps on a intérêt à ce que les
ordonnances soient bien rédigées et que
on laisse le temps quand même au
gouvernement de pouvoir modifier en
fonction des besoins donc on a demandé
tout à l'heure au gouvernement d'aller
le plus vite possible dans la rédaction
de ces ordonnances mais je pense que les
trois mois sont nécessaires pour pouvoir
corriger éventuellement des choses qui
auraient été oubliées donc l'avis de la
commission c'est plutôt un demande de
retrait sinon avis défavorable
merci je mets aux voix l'amendement 4
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
quiconque il est rejeté je mets au voile
article 3 qui est pour
c'est contre il est adopté après
l'article 3 un amendement un peut-être
monsieur Belin
merci monsieur le Président oui je
présente cet amendement au nom de notre
collègue Andrea chaîne
c'était une demande c'est une demande de
rapport par voir les procédures ou
simplifier les procédures de travaux sur
le ministre on a tous connu ça dans nos
collectivités d'avoir des études des
études des problèmes de marché public
des choses qui n'avancent pas
personnellement quand j'étais président
du département sur une simple route
départementale 5 ans d'études pour un an
de travaux les études étaient terminées
qu'il fallait refaire les études parce
qu'elles étaient caduques donc à un
moment donné voilà on a envie que ça ça
soit un peu plus fluide mais je vais pas
vous refaire le propos que j'ai tenu
tout à l'heure à la tribune en tout cas
c'était le sens de l'amendement de notre
collègue nous sommes un certain nombre à
l'avoir retiré mais pour ne pas faire de
perdre avoir signé mais pas pour ne pas
faire de temps et voyez c'est un lapsus
nous le retirons
merci Monsieur Belin je vous précise
immédiatement que j'ai été saisi sur
l'ensemble du texte par une demande de
scrutin public merci de bien vouloir
vous y préparer
monsieur le ministre
d'abord évidemment pour
remercier le sénateur Belin je trouvais
étonnant que quelqu'un qui fasse
l'apologie du sans-papier à la fois dans
son discours et dans sa manière de
s'exprimer demande à ce que le
gouvernement fasse de la paperasse au
bout de 6 mois mais il m'a privé de cet
argument je voudrais puisque c'est le la
fin de cet échange faire passer trois
messages le premier il est pour le
président Larcher et pour la présidente
prima
ça a été dit la réactivité du Sénat avec
ce dépôt d'un texte
dans les heures qui ont suivi pour faire
en sorte que un texte d'urgence puisse
s'engager à marquer très vite la volonté
de la Haute Assemblée de se tenir une
fois de plus au côté des élus et je
voudrais souligner l'excellente état
d'esprit dans lequel la séance
d'aujourd'hui a été préparée et le fait
qu'effectivement malgré un calendrier
qui était arrêté les fonctionnaires de
cette maison et les parlementaires et
pris leur responsabilité pour manifester
de manière concrète leur solidarité et
je voulais vraiment passer ce message à
la fin 2 j'ai bien entendu la demande de
débat les débuts de discussion sur les
causes je vous invite je nous invite à
mettre à profit les semaines qui
viennent avant que ce débat aille lieu
parce que ce qui me frappe c'est que
beaucoup réclament un débat mais pour
arriver tout de suite en disant ça fait
des années qu'on le dit et il s'est
passé ce qu'on a dit
sauf que ceux qui l’expriment l'exprime
parfois avec des mots qui sont
diamétralement opposés et dans la
conséquence de ce qui s'est passé j'ai
l'impression que chaque ancien candidat
à l'élection présidentielle voit la
prophétie auto-réalisée de ce qu'il
avait lui-même dit ce qui va quand même
supposer qu'on est un minimum de travail
de convergence parce que on pourra pas
avoir des explications qui soient toutes
contraires enfin
ce moment il a évidemment un sens c'est
celui de nous trouver au côté des élus
et là aussi il faut pas que ce soit
seulement un moment d'unité nationale
évanescent c'est plus largement autour
des élus locaux du statut de l'appui de
la façon d'aller faciliter leur vie
qu'on aura aussi vocation à se retrouver
à la rentrée c'était les quelques
messages que je voulais passer merci de
m'avoir permis de le faire monsieur le
président carochi
merci monsieur le ministre et merci de
reconnaître encore et encore le rôle du
Sénat monsieur dossier
oui c'est pour une explication de vote
évidemment nous voterons ce texte qui
est attendu c'est un texte d'urgence
mais c'est tout de même symbolique qu'on
soit là aujourd'hui sur cette séance
exceptionnelle
à devoir légiférer 100 jours après les
déclarations du président de la
République qui appelait à 100 jours
d'apaisement et nous voilà 100 jours
après à devoir légiférer en urgence
suite à une flambée de violence qui
montre bien que notre société
est à vif et qu'elle les causes sont
extrêmement profondes alors c'est
évidemment frustrant et je rejoins la
demande de mes collègues de d'avoir un
débat puisque certains ont exquisé
quelle que soit les bancs de l'hémicycle
des commandes d'un début d'explication
sur les causes de cette flambée de
violence mais on n'a pas pu aller plus
loin et on a besoin de ce débat parce
que nous ne mettons pas tous les mêmes
causes derrière derrière ces violences
et donc on est encore aujourd'hui
frustré mais les élus locaux concernés
vous ont écrit monsieur le ministre quel
que soit l'association des lieux dans
lequel ils font ils sont membres et ils
vous ont écrit pour agir vite et pas
uniquement les articles de ce texte de
loi ils ont vous ont fait des
propositions et aujourd'hui si on ne
veut pas que le baril de poudre que sont
devenus parfois nos quartiers
s'enflables à nouveau il va falloir agir
vite sur les causes profondes qui ont
mené à cette formule violence je vous
remercie merci chers collègues monsieur
le Président Retailleau
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du Sénat monsieur le ministre
insatisfaits et puis aussi un regret le
satisfait site c'est d'abord vous
remercier parce que si nous avions eu la
question des copropriétés je pense que
ce texte aurait été beaucoup plus
compliqué pour nous à examiner dans ce
état je sais que vous avez eu un rôle
personnel important bien sûr que nous
allons voter le texte et à chaque fois
que vous raccourcirez des délais que
vous accélérerez que vous simplifierez
vous nous trouverez à vos côtés j'ai
bien aimé tout à l'heure l'expression de
Bruno Belin bien sûr de l'audace plutôt
que de la paperasse le regret c'est
simplement pour dire que c'est un texte
qui est un petit texte c'est un texte
bien sûr qu'il faut reconstruire c'est
un texte qui s'attache à des procédures
et nous aurions aimé que ce texte-là
soit mise en perspective par une analyse
et la parole présidentielle pour qu'on
nous pose un diagnostic pour qu'on
définisse les causes je crois
profondément que ce qu'il va falloir
reconstruire dans les mois dans les
années qui viennent ça n'est pas ce qui
a été brûlé pendant 5 jours et 5 nuits
c'est ce qui a été déconstruit pendant
des décennies l'autorité bien sûr
l'autorité des parents l'autorité du
maître l'autorité de la force publique
l'autorité de la loi et il faudra sans
doute aussi faire en sorte que tous ces
jeunes des quartiers puissent aimer la
France qu'on leur fasse aimer la France
qu'on arrête de présenter la France
comme éternellement coupable voué à
jamais à une sorte de pénitence
perpétuelle si on leur présente la
France comme peu estimable comme peu
aimable il y a peu de chances que ils
puissent entrer dans le destin collectif
national et je voudrais simplement
terminer pour saluer les collègues
questeur bien sûr mais deux collègues
présents de groupe pélianassassiers et
Jean-Claude Riquier leur dire simplement
que j'avais nous avions pour pas
seulement du respect mais une profonde
estime je le dis du fond du coeur
au-delà de divergence c'est aussi cela
merci
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par la commission des affaires
économiques sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à votre tête
le scrutin est clos
dans
exprimé
344 pour
344 contre 0 le Sénat a adopté à
l'unanimité
monsieur le Président du Sénat mes chers
collègues je vais lever la séance la
prochaine séance et le vendredi 21
juillet au matin pour les éventuels
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire sur ce texte dans l'hypothèse
ou cette CMP ne serait pas nécessaire
monsieur le Président du Sénat prendrait
acte de la clôture de la session
extraordinaire lorsque nous aurons reçu
le décret de monsieur le Président de la
République en portant clôture cette
information serait publiée au Journal
officiel et sur le site internet de
notre assemblée sauf élément nouveau le
Sénat se réunirait donc à nouveau le
lundi 2 octobre 2023 15 heures pour
l'élection du président du Sénat la
séance est levée
[Applaudissements]